that's not what he said
he said he does say that oh he does
first of all welcome everybody to the a
street podcast i am your host
maximus my beautiful lovely wife the
icon the ceo
way out of my league yet here we are
good luck ethan
do you have any advice to people who are
trying to date out of their league thank
you keemstar
i just gotta be cool
yeah she thinks i'm cool guys
i still got a chance i got a chance to
make this thing work
wake up wake up okay i was a little bit
late today
a little bit and all y'all are talking
to the live chat about
tanking my wiki feed as um
as punishment okay when the has it been
30 seconds can i curse
give it a view okay when the s hits the
fan
are you still a fan right right i come i
show up a minute late and y'all talk
about tanking my wiki feet i mean come
on where's the loyalty
this is a foot soldier army bro
okay 50 minutes late fine what the [ __ ]
okay maybe i deserve it i think you
deserve a tank
1.1 maybe but i was doing something i
was preparing
to make stand with the tank stop it how
dare you
you stand with the tank about the piece
of love your ass would talk like that
come on man so unpresidential
man there's so much drama in the news i
can't even keep track of it
today we're talking about you know
something so crazy happened on uh
the david dobrik front is that there's
like
a clips channel
oh that's how you said eclipse there's
an eclipse bro the world is ending
there's a clips channel of views the
podcast which is david's podcast
and i think it's a fan they say it's a
fan
account but these this fan account
dug out from the vault him talking about
this seth prank
and the way he talks about it is so
bad it makes it so
much worse you know
and um that's what i was doing i'll take
i'm just trying to
hear you entertain because i want to say
wow i'm just going to say wow you're
still not done yeah i'm just saying wow
wow wow i just said wow right now i'm
gonna go watch
what a tick tock watch live um
go ahead ella it's just i'm almost done
issue podcast boom done done done
done and that was my show i'm done okay
good to go
sorry guys i was just so desperate to
put that up
so before i get into oh then there's
like james charles this
huge dude
james charles just got exposed from
another person he was hitting up and
like
the snaps and this time it's like again
way worse than anything that's ever
happened is that a a new event
it just happened like an hour ago wow oh
no
exactly i don't know it just happened an
hour ago it's already blowing up on
twitter
and like i don't
we're going to talk i'm going to sit on
we're going to talk about what trish on
monday because i'm going to put some
work into it
right wow sister snapped
definitely snapped philly d finally
covered the um
dobrik story i don't want to say that uh
you know i had anything to do with it
but it's nice to see
um it's definitely picking up i saw
articles about it
yeah but like nothing's happening still
you know it's like i don't know how
you can just i didn't know you could
just ignore stuff to this level
yeah it's the start but nobody's i guess
there's no consequence so as long as no
consequence then who cares like i saw
him even being touted in an
anti-bull here you got to see this [ __ ]
uh bullying prevention tour you guys
i've made a tweet i said david dobrik
going on anti-bullying tours like me
going on a tour telling people to lose
weight
it's just nobody should be taking weight
loss advice from me
did they remove his shirt no here he is
yeah
nah that's a huge thing like
that headshot yeah that's the same one i
always say i don't know why he loves
this
why are you touching your face what are
you musing i mean i don't get it
oh this okay we have all kinds of juice
drama he's also blocking we found out
keywords on his vlog
to prevent people from talking about it
anyway we'll get into all this but first
i wanted to mention
hi shredder you saying hi to everyone
i wanted to mention that we have a new
little drop coming out on teddy fresh
gotta hype ila up this is some
ela stuff this shirt finally came out
yes my favorite heavy work shirt by eli
klein
it's a pretty i mean it's really
incredible the detail always wanted to
do
to find a way to like take stuff from my
sketchbooks and
find a way to present it and share it
because you just can't really share
sketchbooks or really even present it so
um this took us a year because we wanted
the shirt to be really
nice and to get the artwork to fit
the way i wanted it on each size too
like
it was a whole thing well it's really
hard to make it look like it's actually
markers
like someone actually just like if you
got it looks like somebody just drawn it
with markers
that's not easy to do so there you have
it that's that that's why
i had to draw on every single one you do
on every singular
um and then also women's pen new
releases women's pants
boom women's pants where are you at here
they are women's pants
boom boom hit him with that oh you got
that rubber patch hit him with it
why'd you have to why'd you have to do
that to him yeah
you didn't have to why'd you have to do
it
why'd you do this what the hell you know
gotta put that extra spice vibe
and i'm gonna take a little credit cause
i designed this one thank you very much
i designed it got a vibe this and the
other one thank you thank you with peace
and love
okay that's it so go to teddyfresh.com
see if there's something you like thanks
all right oh and then another thing
before we get into the
goss in the last episode of the street
podcast we
had this whole fashion show that was
really great
and we were specifically making fun of
this balenciaga shirt
and then of course everyone's like yo
trisha actually bought this shirt yeah
that's so cool
it's pretty funny it comes with two
hangers yeah
that is so funny i like that
so balenciaga made this shirt taking the
piss out
right there and they sold it for like
1300 bucks literally looks like a
project
like this looks like this looks like a
hane shirt i mean she doesn't like it i
think she obviously just bought it for
the gag
uh pretty funny though you know it's a
good guy
it's true that even the shirts they used
are like
like like the trisha said like hangs
just really shitty generic nah
no way the silhouettes that you use you
will not convince me of that and that's
[ __ ] what
this plain blue shirt isn't just i'm not
saying they used hanes
i'm saying the shirts that they use are
like some [ __ ] generic costco stuff
no it's really nice you're crazy
bro are you talking about the same item
i am this yeah
what's what what do you mean i'm sure
it's made of really nice fabrics i know
i'm sure it's made of nice fabrics but
i'm saying that
this shirt on the front looks like
something you would get at costco okay
yeah that's the design okay brother i
know what you were saying
anyway she bought it that was funny what
can i say
yeah yeah i want to see her in it let's
fast forward
oh no not jason get the [ __ ]
no wait can you erase someone from a
video
uh let's see if i can find a shot
without him there you go
bye [ __ ] well don't be stupid that's
so funny
i'm gonna get my boyfriend's opinion on
this when he comes but what do we think
nah you can't approve
in my opinion
[Laughter]
i don't know you guys i don't know daddy
i wonder if she kept it
also look how it like too much yeah
i would like that too it pulls this it's
not even
like you would think if they would they
would at least like engineer something
exactly yeah it just literally pulls
your shirt
yeah which doesn't even spawn i don't
know why i'm even pretending like it's
wearable but i mean you think they would
at least try
no i that's the only one
why not try to get someone in that shirt
i mean it's a fully wearable shirt like
if we got that you could wear that
i could wear the bat yeah
you know why not i'm going to david's
surprise party tonight oh my god could
you imagine i show up in this
i mean it looks like something she made
i don't think people would think it was
what does this have to do with 911
wasabi wabi-wapi or whatever his name is
anyway once again shout out to trisha
for being ahead of the curve as usual
trish is like the sim the youtuber
version of the simpsons she's already
done everything
he's already done it you know
[Music]
people were upset that i was weighing
myself in the
previous episode i get it but i'm not
going to stop because it's my a token of
how committed i am
to this diet it hurts it's painful
it's not healthy but i'm gonna keep
doing it you do it on every episode on
the
middle of the weekend yes i'm gonna do
it once a week in the middle of the week
so that'll be on the thursday episodes
gotcha
i'm committed i am going to stay strong
i'm going to step on that scale and face
my demons every
[ __ ] week and i'm still on keto a
raging state of ketosis which
zach i actually feel fine i feel fine
it's like the word ketosis is funny yeah
am i i'm not alone in that right
no it sounds ridiculous yeah it sounds
like you're undergoing some
chemical reactions like no i just don't
eat carbs it's not that serious
i feel fine though i mean i don't feel
like weird or off or
sleepy or i mean i feel totally fine
good
a little constipated but yeah that's
normal a little bit though not too bad
like i had a couple of bm's that were
super clean that i was happy about
like no i would think the opposite that
carbs would make you
um no way man i'm tight
i'm tight and dry down there
[ __ ] yeah but i don't know man i just
i don't know i was just hoping to see
results faster because
yours was so it seems like people have
such dramatic results with this but
okay i'm gonna stick with it i'm gonna
stick with it man
you're gonna you're gonna get there
you're gonna achieve enlightenment i i
swear to you
thank you guru zach thank you maestro
dude i've been ordering chipotle just
give it a shot just try
for a good amount of time i'm going to
i'm fully committed at least
a month after a month i should see like
real results right zach like it
shouldn't be
it's like oh i did i lost three pounds
no it should be like
[ __ ] 20 pounds right well i mean
again it depends i mean that's a lot it
depends on those [ __ ] lost 70 pounds
in two months i want that
was it it was three months and i was
running
every day and it was young okay you're
changing the story you literally said
two months ago the first time he said
yes he did because i was like wow that's
more than a pound a day how's that
possible
three months three months yeah
okay whatever dude something's a little
bit of a stress
you're setting yourself up to failure
that's a crazy expectation
i'm not quitting okay but don't expect
such a big uh
because then you'll be disappointed you
know ex expect
disappointment and then you'll be happy
ela i have throughout my life
always expected disappointment so why
change
now you feel better like do you feel
are have you noticed the clothes
anything no
i haven't noticed the clothes the
clothes are tight
this shirt barely convinced me this is
the xl i guarantee next week you will
i guarantee you by the way teddy fresh
stuff first of all but he looks better
on you than me
i gotta say it does it does fit you well
and
there was a moment where you started
thinking like maybe i need to excel
that's true and but this fits you well
right now so maybe you just need to like
adjust your expectations
maybe maybe a month ago i wouldn't fit
this yes
because i remember you're starting to
say you're starting to need to excel
that's not good yeah i don't want to be
a 2xl
that's not i can live with xl but 2xl is
like bro just [ __ ]
just [ __ ] well it it really
is just dive to the bottom of that ben
and jerry carter dude because
you've lost the battle it's hard to wear
like
fashionable things i feel like because
i've seen your struggle when i'm like oh
we got all this steady fresh and you're
like i don't want to wear anything
yeah i mean yeah i know it sucks i guess
to give you a little comfort i was a 3x
that was the highest i was doesn't give
me comfort
but well no i mean you haven't reached
3x yet you know you're saying right
you're saying there's still hope even at
3x that is good
yeah yeah right
right you were 3x no i'm kidding
[Laughter]
he's really tall though yeah
how tall are you zach six foot three
three wow what a hunk
[Laughter]
so anyway i am committed oh i've been
eating these uh
chipotles like keto style and it's
so nasty because like there's no rice
there's no beans
so there's nothing to really hold it
together it's just a goo bowl
it's like guac exactly you get
tons of meat basically it gets all the
sauce down guac
sour cream cheese lettuce salsa it's a
gooble and some chicken
you could eat it with a straw basically
yeah
this is sick it is disgusting but it's
in a really weird way it really works
for me whatever you're eating
right now i'm kind of enjoying because i
love
chipotle for example so now we're
ordering chipotle
it's so interesting that you love
chipotle because you're like
i just i find that interesting but i
love it because i
love the bowl with rice and beans are we
getting that for dinner tonight
i can eat that every day until you can
until you can
say chipotle is like all in or all out
yeah
yeah it's kind of interesting eating it
i have to i mean listen i have i'm not
saying this as a meme i have
ex painful explosive diarrhea every time
i chipotle so i feel like that helps in
my weight loss too
oh god it's because you get like all the
salsa
no i don't digest the food it's like i
didn't eat that's when you should weigh
yourself
[Laughter]
okay i'll be performing an enema i'll be
drinking uh magnesium
milk of magnesium it's like it's like
a [ __ ] weigh-in you're still you
know there's a super chatter who said
that zach's running was incidental the
running wouldn't have accounted for that
much of a weight loss
it was the keto you can't outrun a bad
diet team keto
okay uh check this out the chat is
saying that chipotle now has cauliflower
rice
that you could eat that i saw that on
them i saw that on
um on
i've had it it's pretty good can i be
honest with you guys i just i don't like
cauliflower it's a [ __ ] out
to me it's an offensive why you care
about cauliflower
that's good cauliflower is awesome you
care about cauliflower that much you can
tell me get the [ __ ] out
for vegeta you're gonna this cauliflower
is awesome
i like broccoli better what's with
cauliflower they're getting everything
they're in the crust they're the rice
it's like
cauliflower guy needs to take a take a
[ __ ] trip and leave me the [ __ ] alone
the cauliflower marketing is one point
the college flower guys just needs to
win all the awards and just get the [ __ ]
out of my life
i think broccoli needs more marketing
broccoli i like broccoli pretty tasty
the the taste sometimes you have to
you know take a dive on the taste of the
food because you know you will
achieve a better result of losing weight
like sometimes you're just gonna have to
say oh [ __ ] it tastes like [ __ ] but
it's all for the ketosis it's better
than not eating right
sounds like like a um it sounds
like a deadly like condition yeah
i hate to tell you this mrs klein but
your husband is in a cute state of
ketosis
yeah i'll try it i'm going to try
tonight zach the cauliflower
rice
broccoli soup thank you villa
i agree it's great you should make a
tick tock to show people how to make it
[ __ ] you
right i'm i should do i should be making
tick tocks
because that broccoli soap is like a
life hack
it kind of is a life hack it's so simple
it tastes great and then you can consume
so much broccoli without even thinking
about it all right papa flex
you're on the beer on the your honor
come over here
[Laughter]
um i should you're right ela just tell
me because i'm always looking for new
tick tock content because i'm basically
like a tick talker now
that one is great you got to show how to
make that okay
sounds good so honestly even your quiche
would be pretty so easy to make easy to
you
i have no idea how to do it bro oh my
god okay so
oh you have to watch my tick tock it
makes it like without even looking up a
recipe like who can make your quiche
without looking up a recipe
all right well i just made it i made it
once and then
you just get better at it that's how i
like to cook it's like you either you
get it from like my my brother told me
about this recipe or you look one online
you get the idea of basically how to do
it and then
now since i know basically how to do it
i started doing it myself and figuring
out how i like it
yeah i think most people can't do that
really
i guess i'm a genius yeah
that's so funny what the [ __ ]
you should play the rice back
[Laughter]
all right you guys want to talk about
david dobrik look i know you
i know some of you don't like hearing
about this but i do feel this is
important
and you guys are going to enjoy this
because it's so crazy
you know to begin with even i didn't
really think i cared enough about david
dobrik's story
but the more i learned about it i just
really am surprised that no one is
talking
about it like in a serious way this is a
serious
well you know situation it's super
serious
and what's fascinating to me is his
ability to just
ignore ignore ignore it's like that uh
i would feel like if that happened to me
i would have to just like
go bury myself in and and just and
like end it like there's no acknowledge
it like right away
but he's like shaggy one me i saw you in
the bathroom
it wasn't me that's david right now
no matter how a girl there's some joke
how much
how guilty you look like the person that
was in the situation
he's saying he was assaulted saying it
it was so bad to him he had to move
states like how we're just gonna brush
over that
point but he had to move and wait till
you see this video i have for you today
because this for me
puts it all in perspective but until
then
i was watching his new uh episode of
views because like
i was this is the wrong video that
you're setting up
this is the comment section yeah this is
what this is yeah
he's been filtering comments out because
i was looking through his comments
like i saw on tick tock all the top
comments were like when are you gonna
respond to this that thing
and i was like oh wow so people are
aware of this and that went back 20
minutes later they're all gone
then i went to his youtube and there was
like literally
nothing about it and i was like wow
that's so weird so we did some tests to
see what keywords
and but to be fair it is hard sometimes
to say
people throw that accusation very freely
when a lot of times i know i just want
to say that a lot of times youtube just
mixes up the comments all the time so
people will think
that's true everyone is deleting
comments like people say that
by the way it frustrates me i just want
to acknowledge that you know that is
another side of that and it gets thrown
away all the time and
everyone well the other thing that
happens is top comments on youtube are
always
um or not but a lot of times youtube
like
rotates them yes so there's a big topic
but so people always accuse you of
of so what we did to make absolute sure
is that we
first of all would put something on his
channel
and see if we would get through it is
enough oh
like this yeah if it did not go through
then we would go to our channel where we
know it's not being filtered
and see if we would go through because
sometimes how do you know if it went
through
well here because well because it shows
right right ab
you can see it in the chat if it doesn't
go through you can't see it in the chat
when you refresh
right and i double checked on a separate
account
you can always see it yourself so what
what you do
[Laughter]
these guys ring
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so what you do is for okay let's say i
want to see if kiss
for example is blocked so i will go and
write kiss
now you see it from your own account so
you would switch to a different account
sort by new and if it's not there
then it means it's blocked sometimes
youtube blocks itself
right through their own automated you
know
filter so then you go to my channel the
podcast channel
type kiss switch accounts it's there
that means he definitely has it blocked
so he has blocked kiss and kissing
i wouldn't say definitely but i would
say most likely i would say
okay so very very i mean there's no 100
percent proof but
you know it's most likely it's very high
up there
so he's blocked kiss and kissing
we've proven that right i came in here
we were gonna do this whole
the sa i don't want to say it don't even
show it sa
you guys know is also blocked a bit
because you guys walked in
with a security guard so that is blocked
that's fine it's fine just don't say it
essay
and uh uh one test yeah so
sa when posted on ours was not removed
interestingly you know what i mean
so he is filtering out comments
very sly of course um
now here's where it gets really well you
guys i'm just going to play this video
and you watch it this is
candid take from his podcast after
the prank took place you guys just
watched this it's a it's five
minutes long but i swear to god it's
worth every single second
so let's listen you know what i
don't want to show that image of them i
don't want to do that
i need something else to show just open
another window and put it over it you
know
i'll just do it like this let's talk
about this what really made me happy
but today we pulled a prank on
on my friend seth oh it's great yeah
yeah and now you can talk about it it's
probably the best prank i've ever
i've ever pulled on anyone in my opinion
it was we have this scary mask
that we've been pranking people with and
it's just a scary mask and everyone
knows
that that it's it's a mask
and i told him i told seth hey man i
want to do this bit
it's like a dream sequence where you
where you make out
with the masked guy and it just looks
like you're dreaming and you're making
out with an old man because
the mask makes you look like an old man
and i'm like karina's going to be in it
and current is a girl
in my vlogs and he's like and he's he
thinks karen is really attractive so
is kind of like the hot girl in david's
vlogs yeah so he's like
so he's like yeah i'm totally down and
i'm like yeah seth just don't hold back
you can make out as much as you want
have as much tongue as you want just
keep kissing her and
but what so this part is really
interesting to me because
he explicitly explains how
he misled him he's totally confirming
everything
we know even in greater detail because
he's he
because when you watch the video you go
why are they making out so hard yeah
he explicitly instructed him to kiss
hard and he's saying it's a girl that he
thought was attractive yeah like so
clearly it was
interesting exactly what seth didn't
know
is that i replaced corinna with jason
so jason was under the match jason white
okay you
let's watch okay that's why okay sorry
i'm gonna play i'm playing
and everyone's everyone everyone in the
room's like this isn't gonna work
everyone doubted you yeah yeah everyone
brandon corinna like this isn't gonna
work this is stupid because of the size
difference because the size about six
feet
is about five centimeters and then so i
gotta pause because that's another
important point to call out
because a lot of people's evidence that
it's fake is because how could he not
notice the size difference and so he
explicitly says
this is something we were worried about
yet it still worked
again it starts going and seth is there
sitting on the couch
jason walks in as karina he's not
speaking obviously
sits next to her seth leans in and as
he's leaning
in i'm like [ __ ] yeah i got it
it's game over it's in the bag i sit
down i put my hand
i put my hand on seth's knee and i put
my hand behind his back and start
rubbing his back and squeezing his knee
and then he just just leans in
and just goes at it i slip him the
tongue first
okay very incriminating so gross to
think about when you know how set
feels yeah that has been assaulted it's
really gross even listen don't say that
so here is very incriminating
he jason says he slipped the tongue
first
and grabbed his knee
so jason made the first move which by
the way what
what is wrong with you dude
okay with tongue
they start making out and at this point
we're like five seconds in
and i'm like this is it this is what i
wanted i got what i wanted i'm out like
we can end this
and i'm like seth seth like i'm ready to
talk he's coming now he's coming into my
mouth with his tongue
so hard you could tell his tongue is did
he grab my ass
he grabbed your ass he grabs jason's ass
because he thinks it's corinna
at this point the poor dude probably has
a boner
and he's really making out with jason
and i'm like seth
seth seth and i'm trying to get him to
stop but hey jason you know you could
stop
it too right like i'm sorry what
yeah how could
jason subject him how could i mean first
of all jason it
let's get playing out of the bit and he
keeps going
for 25 seconds literally i'm not over
exaggerating it's in the vlog 25 seconds
i'm sorry i have to pause but like he's
like blaming seth you know it's like
he keeps going it's like humiliating to
him he keeps going it's like
you guys could have stopped it any time
i think she's making out with this girl
that he thinks is hot so
and she's a willing participant right
like jason's all in why is it
confusing to them that he kept going and
speaking out with this guy and i'm like
i i literally i think i looked up to the
ceiling and i'm like god what did i do
to deserve such a
beauty and i'm sitting there going again
i gotta pause it
what did i do to dessert he looks up to
the ceiling i thought he was gonna say
something like okay this has gone too
far
no he goes what did i do to deserve such
beauty
dude i'm telling you this clip is from
another world and just remember his
fan a fan account posted this
like what this morning or yesterday man
crazy
david call it please please just call it
david brink her in
it's going on and on and it is so
aggressive like they're making out like
super aggressive and then i call karen
into the room
and karen is standing right next to me
and then and then i'm like seth
seth and then seth finally lets up after
25 seconds of making out with jason
and he sees karina and he just [ __ ]
loses it
yeah it was it was my favorite you can't
fake that
you know it was just it wouldn't be
something you could ever fake it was so
perfect and i feel so bad
and it's just it's it's awful because
poor guy had to go through that
and his friends are probably going to
chew him out for that for the next like
three five years of his life well it's
really important
i feel so bad but thank you god for this
joyous occasion
and i know here's his life he's going to
be running for three to five years
so important i know he's gonna get [ __ ]
for this for three to five years
yeah i know and and then meanwhile he's
plotting the next time he's going to do
it again
seth tells that the homosexuality is not
so accepted in his where he comes from
that's from okay okay we're sorry okay
i'm sorry it's just
let me go back he's not so accepted in
his where he comes from
that's from compton dudes kissing dudes
is not so excited that's from compton so
it's like be perfect like these straight
dudes kissing
literally the perfect setup like a guy
from compton
and i made him make out with another
older man it's good for sex
it gets him it gets him some air time
and seth was really
getting it gets him air time
this is so twisted what a way to justify
it in your head
like yeah it's gonna ruin his life back
in his community for three to five years
but he gets
his air time
the fact that he knows he's literally
explaining in every way how and why it's
so messed up what he did
he says where he comes from kissing
other dudes is not acceptable he's from
compton i know that about him
which does confirm that he is he did
because we know he specifically targeted
him yeah and it and i think this all but
confirms he did it because he's black
and he's from compton
he literally just admit that it couldn't
be a more perfect setup a guy from
compton making out with an older guy
yeah
bragging about it i mean it's so
uh it's it's so sadistic
you know and then to have done this and
to do it again
like he's plotting to do it again so
here we go
initiated into the video he was as angry
as he could have been but he really
couldn't because he was just like
okay you okay again he says he's he's as
angry as he could have been
i mean he handled it really well it was
he he was he gave it up he was like i
don't know what to say that was great
a hundred percent that had to be one of
my favorite pranks it just it was
it just worked so so about him being a
good sport i want to tell a little
anecdote i've been really deep into this
true crime stuff
and there's one really interesting um
episode i saw i think it was dateline or
something like that
a guy was friends
with his neighbor very close friends
straight guy
christian guy they were really close
friends turns out his best friend his
neighbor
is a gay man and so he goes on
like sally jesse raphael or one of these
trashy talk shows of the time
and he says hey and they tell
they tell the guy you have a secret
admirer do you want to come on the show
he says sure so he comes on the show and
it turns out his secret admirer
is his best friend his best friend who's
gay and he's in love with him
and this guy is from a super
conservative family
whose parents like are not down with
that and and so anyway he plays along
with it he's like
he plays along with it he's like oh man
you got me it's so good you know because
he's on television
he's shocked he's in the moment it's
it's kind of natural to be like
you have seth explained an interview
it's like you have two choices you know
either you
throw hands or you just kind of just
say it's already done i'm in the good
graces of david i just
i'm just going to endure it you know
and so and it's on camera you know and
so
back to the story so the best friend
brought he felt he
brought him on tv humiliated him
uh by coming out to him and trying and
he was insinuating that he thought he
was gay and that he wanted to be with
him and
if it was the humiliation of doing it on
tv that a few days later
when you watch the clip it seems like
it's all good and he's like nah he's
laughing and smiling
a few days later he actually murders his
best friend
because he was so distraught he was so
troubled by what happened and the
how he was humiliated that he he
committed so
that my point is is that just because
he's playing along and on camera
doesn't mean anything no it's
skill it can be and clearly was for seth
as he says
so traumatic
i just find it interesting that he
acknowledges he couldn't have been more
mad at the same time
right
it's so it's so [ __ ] up dude it's
honestly
it's just it's so [ __ ] up when you had
um you told me jack's hand was cut open
because heath was throwing dishes and
when i found out i was like
[ __ ] that was good you got them yeah no
i love the i love the making out pranks
like i gotta give it up when you give it
up
no it was great but um but yeah that's
that's all the time we have for today
guys
but yeah let us know definitely tweet us
about what you thought about the podcast
let us know how much you hate us
let us know how much jason deserves and
percentages
um check out my vlog check out my
youtube channel check out all of jason's
speed my kids watch watch my ads is that
too much to say is that gravity
please come to jason's house and give
him money you know i want to say to the
people that do watch my
youtube channel thank you so much i
think that's it
so i feel like it couldn't
be any worse really that clip for david
that clip is just yeah
it's troubling and he's and then and
then you top it all off
with the fact that he went and did it
again and now
after seth is coming to terms with how
traumatized he is by this
he is refu he's blocked him and refusing
to acknowledge it
that is the biggest part
for me is like
even after all this time he still didn't
have
the like personal development
on himself david to like understand what
he did was wrong and
try to make it better try to fix
something
i think my take on david is that
he's so on top of the world in so many
ways
that he's afraid he's not he doesn't
care about doing the right thing
he just wants to do whatever keeps
gives him the best chance of maintaining
his current status
and for him he real i think he knows or
maybe suspects i don't know what would
happen
probably be better if he acknowledged
this as soon as seth had a problem with
it
because now he's in this position where
at any point
i mean i don't know
he's not he's not at all concerned about
what's doing what what's right
he knows that he thinks if he
acknowledges it in any way
then everybody's going to become aware
of it and then all of his partners and
sponsors and all these huge things he's
involved with
are all the sudden gonna be like wait a
minute i didn't know that you did this
so for him it's like i don't
think he sees it as an option to even
acknowledge it
evidenced by the fact that he's like you
know deleting comments and stuff and
yeah blocking seth's number i mean dude
you could have just talked to him on the
phone
and he said he wouldn't even come on our
podcast if you would have just answered
his call
and by the way i think seth has a really
good uh
case for a lawsuit for what
they did to him you know for damages
and for the trauma i [ __ ] it i would sue
him if i was seth i won't even feel bad
especially because he ignores him and
refuses to talk to him and make it right
your hairband is so cute thank you
i love you you're the greatest ever so
beautiful
stop stop
thank you hey
yay it's crazy man you know it's like
and now on top of this with the like
david with the new james charles [ __ ]
which i'm gonna talk about on monday
because
i just came out and i want to look into
it more but like
these creators and these influencers
cannot stop this madness
just stop the madness essays
i don't know it's really weird for me
like how did they not
just you say essay i got you got you
gotcha
i i didn't i thought you were saying
essay no i don't know
s a the letter s the literature did
people understand why you're not saying
it yeah because i don't want to get my
whole [ __ ] channel deleted
okay um i just can't understand
people who don't care about other people
i don't know like are they just they
just don't have that capability
they just don't care if i
because i feel like we've been through
some things we didn't always do the
right thing but
we would always immediately try to make
i think on one hand and try to do
whatever we can to fix things like how
do you not
i don't know i think david just has like
a dude i i honestly don't know
i think he just has too much to lose and
he's like super scared
even then but ultimately you have to do
the right thing yeah
if you don't i mean but human ignoring
this i feel like is going to make it
worse and worse
it's it is in my head it's only getting
worse and worse
why why are you ignoring this this is a
really serious situation
i feel like this video clip actually now
makes it
so much more urgent and messed up it's
like proof that he did it because he's
black
proof that he knew it was messed up that
he was not happy about it that it was
real and then on and then then he went
and did a second i don't know bro
it's it's a lot it's seriously just it's
a lot to handle
yeah um yeah so he's going on the
anti-bowling tour
in context of all this
which is funny because even besides seth
you have big nick
who left for being bullied basically
here he is no place for hate virtual
high school tour
national tour dedicated to promoting
bowling prevention
featuring david dobrik
those of you guys who found the vlog to
be offensive i'm sorry you did for those
of you who didn't
want to be offensive i'm sorry they did
the perfect apology for the
you better take that on tour that kind
of apology
his his vlogs are literally him bowling
people
like that's the whole premise of his
vlogs i mean they say it's just jokes
and stuff and they're all in on it but
that's literally the premise
even if you take it at face value and
say there's no victims which we know
there's not
that's the premise is that yeah he's
like the cool kid bully
wake up okay
i'm so wild bro
can i say about david no i
okay i've always disliked the tongue
thing
i just can put that out there now that
we're on this topic the tongue thing has
always driven me crazy
why he gotta always smile with his
tongue you always gotta smile with his
tongue up
keep the tongue in your mouth please i'm
begging you i don't i just
dude look at every you didn't notice his
tongue is always sticking out like he
thinks it's so cute
and it's not like a i think i heard him
talk about it yeah
it's always it's not like a medical
thing by the way i think i heard him
explain it so i'm not making fun of
something he can't control he literally
just thinks it's cute
he's tongue out guy can we stop the
tongue out please
oh jesus like it's
what's happening my laptop what's
happening wait do you see that no
why is it doing that on the screen no
that document was
scrolling you find me a picture of him
smiling without his tongue out look
one two all right three going off topic
here
it's the tongue out guy put the tongue
in you can smile however
he wants oh there you go well he's not
smiling though
oh that one's a little bit even here you
see his tongue peeking out
why are you guys dying to keep the
tongue in bruh
it's not quite soy face but it's like
it's just silly face so i face adjacent
for sure like this is a lot it's fully
sticking out of his mouth
this is almond milk face i'm just gonna
do that to you all the time
how do you smile like that oh like that
that's good
it doesn't make me cute you look cute
yeah i don't know i don't know how
that's done i don't know if
that i don't know how that doesn't
bother people like i've always been like
dude stop with the tongue out
because he's always i know this is
beside the point but since we're on the
topic
beside the point we're talking about i'm
basically
oh look it's us
tongue out tongue out i'm just telling
you tongue out all right i'm out
i'm out i'm going to be david dovrick's
tongue and
get out of this topic
you know keemstar oh so philly d finally
covered it
after i called him a coward which i take
no pleasure in by the way but he could
have covered this story two weeks ago
but it worked right
so shout out to philly dee shout out to
his family apparently yeah
sup sup sup stuff to his family
what else you got on the agenda
keemstar of course who's known he really
cares about it he says
should i cover again he's avoiding this
because
[Music]
should i cover this david dobrik jason
ash 2017 kissing prank some are calling
some are calling it's like bro it's not
something
it's on video the guy who goes
immediately
right to our allegations
very important this is the guy who just
throws our allegations
with like no sliver of anything
all of a sudden he's not sure if to even
cover the story
and he's gotta ask on twitter
by the way somehow that's [ __ ] up
somehow the majority said they don't
want it which to me is because it's like
the king cold it's like the fact that
he's already asking he's already letting
you know he doesn't care about the story
and also there's no context because if
you don't know what it is you're like oh
it's just from 2017
it's a prank like who cares so
manipulative it's the way he phrased it
it's like most of the people are gonna
say no he's such a dude like i literally
can't
no i'm not a good person right
that is clear that is
very very clear to me how do you feel
about the
uh nam let's not go there try not to get
demonetized this week
the last like six episodes have been
demonetized so i'm like come on i just
want to make just throw me a bone here
youtube
talking about essays talking about jays
talking about rs you know what i'm
saying
trying to get some cheddar how does
anyone even understand what we're
talking about
sorry guys we
are last would you say six episodes or
not monetize
yeah of of of after dark because they're
live
six in a row it's brutal yeah
soul crushing logan paul claims to one
of them nice
stupid ass which we've been disputing
he's doing this thing where he's letting
it expire so it takes like two months to
get rid of it
nice such a dude i'm a strawberry
eventually though yeah it'll go away
eventually but i don't like seeing the
yellow
and like he's being such a douche about
it by letting it expire instead of just
being like all right fine
it's just impossible he's impulsive
i can't wait to watch him move to puerto
rico man it's going to be awesome i
don't really give a [ __ ] but thanks for
letting me know
uh logan on covid ladies and gentlemen
logan on
covet
hey logan i was uh i just hate to let
you know but
i was around people that had coveted and
we i know we hung out recently
and i was told by the contact racers to
let you know that you may have been
exposed to covet what do you think about
that
i don't really give a [ __ ] but thanks
for letting me know
it's funny but that's literally what he
said so
i'm a [ __ ] blueberry
anyway that's what i've got for david
all right
but i've got a bunch of other great
stuff to talk about
like what what i'm holding my tongue so
hold it on you know you hold it and you
keep on holding it
it's so hard to hold my tongue on
something that happened
sometimes you gotta be you all think i
shouldn't say anything about this
no yeah and i'm gonna let you all know
ethan's gonna be the better person
and you just trust us today okay let's
talk about ab no
no zach
by the way by the way
hold on i can talk about it without
showing
the no no one agreed to this you can't
do this
it's tempting as it is i think even even
zach
even zach ian maybe you surprised me
definitely not really yeah no you're
living
how can you guys be so against this
because it's such a bad idea
as your as your number one symptom i
gotta say yeah you you gotta move but i
can't
i feel like i'm gonna have to be the
better person i feel like i'm gonna
have to it's just where is jealousy
thank you can we get a little
yeah let me just let me hear what joel
osteen has to say i better get some
inspiration quick
love you guys have no idea what we're
talking about what do you think
i think you should talk about it no
hit me with the affirmation come on
gerald talk me out of it
people don't have the final say some of
the doors
that should stop you you're going to see
them open
of their own accord of their own it
wasn't anything now you open it
you can't take credit for it what you
have done they've been
bigger more powerful but somehow
you defeated goliath that sickness
should have been the end
but the door opened of its own occasion
i feel like you could it was it's so
creepy
no that was perfect for me i'm starting
to believe in jokes
i'm starting to believe in joel play me
one more because that one was
inconclusive
no that was it was going to get worse i
know it that was perfect
[Music]
i don't understand how you guys all
think it's such a bad idea how can i not
it was just so beyond
okay i can skip for now but like i don't
know if i can hold on to this forever
i don't know if i'm mature enough do you
want to be a cool guy
for me like i told you in the beginning
that you're cool
yeah i do you gotta be cool jack hey you
gotta be cool all right i know
everyone's gonna be mad that i didn't
say anything but just
know that literally everybody here even
zack
unanimously agreed that i shouldn't talk
about it so i guess you just have to
i think you guys the foot soldiers
should be proud of it and even though
you don't
know what it is well hold on hold on
proud of him for being the better person
do you think that if me talking about
this is
are you guys worried about the other
person are you worried about me
it's both both everything yeah
everything
come on man even joe even joe
really even joe how could it how could
it go bad for me
yeah because you're not gonna be a cool
guy
you will it'll take you out of ketosis
well i'll just say someone just was
someone
sent me some extremely belligerent
messages that just blew me the [ __ ] away
yeah and that's right and we're just
gonna just to give you a simple premise
not everything has to make it to the
show is my opinion
you know i disagree with that yeah
you don't surround yourself with yes man
no everybody said no to me yeah you
surround yourself with no man which is
good
if you surround yourself with yes man
you end up in the suicide forest
shooting next to a dead body you know
it's like not everything should make it
into the footage
don't become a
a suicide forest guy basically
can i just give a one no that's it right
okay all right i'm out
putting our food down all right
it wasn't by the way just see it wasn't
post malone if that's what you guys were
thinking i don't want it
because i know that people it's just
it's not anyone it doesn't matter no
because i
don't want anyone to draw conclusions
about who it was it's nobody you would
guess
there was no it's nobody you again
because he's an idiot yeah
yeah no i don't want
people to start speculating of like oh
he got in a fight with post malone
because we were talking about it or just
i don't want people
to start speculating about who it was
okay well you
shouldn't have even talked about it it's
nobody you would guess it's nobody you
would guess i'll just say that
all right dalia wasn't dalia
i wasn't dalia i'm telling you you
wouldn't guess you will never guess
don't even try
it it's so out of vote yeah ethan's
telling the truth
yeah it it literally would be impossible
to guess because it's so absurd
it wasn't shane ryan it wasn't anyone i
don't want you guys yeah
you'll never guess don't speculate
i feel like it's going to come out in
due time just work these like joe said
joel yeah he said let the dough open
itself play one more
no one more play one more drill nothing
conducted you played that [ __ ] joe
last time were you guys so
lucky well i wasn't even coming so like
you played that joel osteen song play it
either scared what joel might say
you played that joel osteen it was too
perfect you played that [ __ ]
joel austin okay
but but we already made up our minds
okay fair enough
all right
uh i declare that you are a people
builder
you will look for opportunities to
encourage others
by bringing out the best in them and to
help them
accomplish their dreams you will speak
words of faith
and okay stop it joel's right by the
cube
what if joe what if joe was like you
will tell him about those textbooks
right
you will have the final word oh that's
good
just all vengeful jokes the cube works
yeah joel's right
i'll be i will be a people builder
[Applause]
kenneth wants me to talk about it i'm
healed of jesus kenneth is
every time i first of all we mentioned
him a few episodes what was the context
i said something like
you just you only backed in his name
because you accidentally
you were trying to refer to little uzi
vert yeah little tracy you got to
confuse
you always again it was just passing and
he went off again
little tracy is very sensitive to me
mentioning him because
after that brief mix-up he literally
tweeted out like
h3 podcast keep my [ __ ] name out of
your mouth
[Laughter]
he's got beef with me yeah should i be
afraid of little tracy not like you
i really think we should be friends is
that a bad word about him no trace
um i don't think i've ever said a bad
word about ian is he is he like a scary
rapper
or is he like i'm not really that
familiar with him i don't know
but i don't think you got to worry no no
no
i think we should be friends i think we
should come on the podcast i agree
lil tracy if you want to call and
discuss i'd love to hear from you
because i just think it's funny like
you're you're so aware of any time i say
and it upsets you so much which i don't
get
no ill will here is he good why did
little vert
why did a little vert take off and
little tracy didn't well then don't go
there we talked about him let's just not
even go there
he was he was in the the origin story
for little nos
x because yeah like the cowboy right
right
how was it it wasn't even about
you want to watch a fun vid pretty quick
crazy so
this is a zoom fiasco
so there's a yeah this one's pretty bad
a college
professor berates a student who is hard
of hearing
on zoom without knowing that she's hard
of hearing
you can only imagine the setup already
is pretty
juicy i've been talking to you miss
salazar
yeah oh my god wait how
are they supposed to participate and
zoom then so
as i understand for watching it she has
something in her ear that translates
what he says really loud for her so she
can hear it but it just it comes late
yeah this guy does not like it
miss salazar i've been talking to you
miss salazar i can hear you a little bit
you can hear me a little bit why didn't
you answer all the times i answered i
spoke to you then
you know thank you thank you why don't
you yes
why don't we talk sometimes why don't
you email me we'll set up a live zoom
and we're going to have some real
communication at some point in time
okay maybe you can have your counselor
join us
okay oh my god will you hear me that's a
teacher
okay wonderful do that it's crazy like
professor she's actually hard of hearing
so her translator
goes in a little bit she can't respond
like
right away she's not paying attention
she's not trying
oh my god i love how he's not like oh
i'm so sorry
how does he not know that about her if
he's the teacher
look there's even if he didn't yeah they
just explained it to him and like
doubled down on being a douche you know
when you're angry and then you realize
you're totally wrong but you're not
ready to give up being angry
yeah but that doesn't sound like a good
what's that
this is a curb bit this this is a real
life curve bit
but larry dave would be like oh you're
deaf like he would i feel like
your dad just told me a story that's
totally like what was the story
but it was good tell me my dad's story
he told a good story
it was a story about how he's becoming a
better person
oh my god my dad's telling you anecdotes
okay because normally
he said like he has a like customer
support because he owned the shop
if people don't give customer support is
there is a stickler for it
and so he will say something and then um
he was walking to a cashier and trader
joe's and the guy didn't greet him or
say anything
and uh your dad said normally he would
have said something
first of all stop my dad is the only
[ __ ] in the world
who's going to complain about someone
else
i [ __ ] pray together talk too much
people are driving me crazy they're tall
they chat me up i don't care like
how are you going to make small talk
like i know i'm leaving out of your life
in 30 seconds i don't care to get to
know you always ask like so what do you
plan for this evening
no you don't care and i don't care that
you know so your dad
said normally he would have been upset
and said something but he was holding
his thong
oh my god not saying anything what do
you want to say something to the manager
or something or to the guy like how come
you
are not yeah and
uh and then he found out that the guy
was deaf
i'm sorry but that's not an excuse if
you're gonna work on trader joe's you
better [ __ ]
say what's your plans for the day deaf
or not
you can still verbalize something
so that's his whole story so it's a good
story for your dad
growing up god i can't believe my dad
actually
like wants to be chit-chatted yeah it's
because of
people like him and zach that i have to
deal with this
pointless [ __ ] why can't you say
hello
i don't want to tell the trader joe's
cashier what my plans are for the
weekend
i don't want to be forced into that
situation
i don't want to even be put in that
situation where i have to say
anything about what my plans are for the
weekend oh
here's what i'm gonna say they go what
are you up to this weekend i'll say
nothing okay but now i feel like an
[ __ ] yeah
now you're like they know you're doing
i'm doing something
but i'm not gonna expand anymore i don't
[ __ ] care about them
you know okay zach what do what would
you say what's the correct answer what
would you say
good question uh hanging out chilling
come on whatever you want you can lie to
them you know oh
so we gotta go there we gotta like
invite them over well yeah i mean
oh you're not doing anything this
weekend you want to hang out oh my god
you know you're good that won't ever
happen if someone tried to hang out with
me i'd never come back to that store
by the way a girl could never say that
well i mean that's true zack you would
never you would don't say that
don't even joke that you would try to
hang out with the cashier no no no i'm
just
you know i'm being i'm kidding right now
okay but you know
peace and love yeah no i'm kidding
what are you up to this weekend i'm
going to my mom i'm going to my
grandma's funeral
then i got to check out my dad who's on
live support in the hospital i'm sorry
to hear that they're not picking up an
eight ball of heroin i gotta shoot up to
chase my problem
sounds like a great time well i hope you
have a fantastic day sir
how am i gonna have a fantastic week did
you not just hear what i said
[ __ ] you don't ask
honestly i'll be honest with you i don't
i prefer not to go to trader joe's
because
like i'll tell you i of i'll
why trader joe's why can't it happen at
like a ralph's because trainer b
they're like especially talkative they
encourage their cashiers to chitchat you
you can tell they always give you the
same [ __ ] line of questioning how
was your
day how's your weekend what are you up
to you know i'll tell you what i
i love you know what else they do
they're like oh you got this chocolate
oh i got to show you there's another one
that i love
they always do that i know and i need to
check out to like yes
did they do that to you no i'm i don't
think they always
do that to me and i end up buying
whatever they bring me because i want to
be nice because you feel bad
and and you're like i don't want that
especially one time why are you
pregnant remember when i was pregnant we
were buying
uh all of a sudden i wanted a bunch of
chocolate and we bought a bunch of stuff
and she was like oh my god i gotta go
get you some of the stuff that i love
and she went off the cashier
grabbed some stuff and i bought it even
though i didn't even want it because i
wanted to be nice but it's like wait
so did you before you had the option of
saying i'm okay she just ran off and to
get it
what do you want to say no no no she was
like oh my god
do you know the pretzel filled thing a
little bit and i was like no i don't
know it she's like okay wait i gotta go
get it
zach it's not okay it just people are
being i'm not
going to trader joe's because i know the
cashier is going to chat with me and
i'll tell you i'll go
sometimes when i'm at trader joe's i'll
line up the cashiers and try to go to
the one that looks like the most [ __ ]
anti-social i get anxious
i get anxious checking out at trader
joe's because i know these [ __ ]
are going to try to talk to me
it's just so just divert the
conversation bill i'm good
and then they'll shut up hard i'm good
i'm good well i try and then they they
sometimes still go after me they go hey
how are you doing today fine what are
you up to this weekend nothing
and it's like have a great day take the
[ __ ] cue and then they keep asking me
[ __ ]
well that's on them then well
yeah but it still happens
all right so when you go to chick-fil-a
they kind of do the same thing yeah i
don't [ __ ] like
chick-fil-a you don't [ __ ] with
chick-fil-a i go to chick-fil-a but
nobody catch me up there
i they have some policy where they they
have to chat you up
maybe it's you zach yeah maybe no no no
no no no when they say when you say
thank you they have to say my pleasure
that's not true that's a sign
it doesn't require a response from you
it's a i
no i'm good with my pleasure i don't
want anyone asking me questions
okay why do they gotta get the last word
though why why do you why do they have
to say my pleasure why do you have to
leave
with them bro say whatever you want just
say k
okay but you're right my pleasure is
kind of like the ultimate end you can't
follow that thing
you know it's my pleasure
i know the pleasure was all mine the
pleasure was all mine [ __ ]
right wonderful for responding to that
it's so awkward because what are you
supposed to do like you throw them the
peace sign or like
just drive because it's awkward
how is that awkward they're literally
saying goodbye
i guarantee you to them it's like
robotic they they just automatically say
it
before that it's even left their mouth
they're thinking about the next order
that they're going to handle but
it feels awkward it feels awkward it's
not even when i'm starving or like
i gotta pee real bad it just feels
awkward so you feel like you need to
reply after my pleasure what do you say
like oh have a good day okay
zach your life is just this is my hell
because i'm always like like concerned
like oh like if you go into a store then
this is gonna happen
like oh i gotta stand behind this guy or
you know like
was he gonna say something is he gonna
say hello like you know
wait what what so you're becoming one of
them
yeah you're not making any sense zach
i'm
all i'm saying it's okay to talk to your
cashier at your local trader joe's so
then
okay i can't i can't i'm done with this
i need to exit this conversation
it was a pleasure talking to you yeah no
you damn
have a nice day the pleasure was all
mine
[Laughter]
all right let's finish with this
professor parading this poor hard of
hearing girl
are you her translator out to gail
oh my god yeah he's such a dick oh my
god
it's slower on her and because she needs
to get it translated and then
it goes to her it goes to her hearing
piece
okay well her salazar have your
counselor speak with me because you've
got too much distraction
to even understand what's going on yes i
don't
[Music]
next to know explaining me everything
that you're saying
okay just have them teach you
the whole class that makes sense to me i
don't know
i don't understand it but
i see uh laughing and smiling and
giggling with somebody else
it doesn't seem like i mean like why
should i be in a bad mood
you shouldn't be in a bad mood you
shouldn't pay attention to classes
all right whatever okay this guy's not
fit
you're sorry whatever
okay bro whatever
i understand somebody caught his ass
big time on zoom counselor
[Music]
he's like listen have your counselor
contact me
period i'm trying to get fired contact
them
contact them i want to lose my job as
soon as possible
arguing with me okay like i'm
disrespecting you
and you're just like i love his zoom
background
what's his background oh
oh my god
dude somebody got him so good wow by the
way it's so weird to like berate
somebody in front of everyone like yeah
i guess that's what school's like though
man thinking back on school people used
to catch
a lot of [ __ ] in class in front of
everyone
bad vibes only yeah school sucks i still
have
dreams where i wake up when i'm at
school and i wake up and i'm like oh my
god i don't know how i did school it's
literally the worst
it's the worst school is the [ __ ] if
you're in school
just know it's the [ __ ] worst like
it's almost like prison you get out and
you cannot believe the freedom you have
right you you can't believe it you're
you're no longer
obligated to this [ __ ] when you're
at home
so i'll tell you why school is
especially [ __ ] up i feel like school
needs to be performed
you're at school and then you have to do
all this [ __ ] when you get home
it's like when you work you at least
have like free time work time you
you work all day you come home you have
free time right you can't balance
it's just the homework things can be so
overwhelming
also the teachers i mean for example
this guy
this teacher in this video gave me
flashbacks to teachers that i used to
have yes
me too that was my problem with school
it's like if my teacher is a dumbass
how am i gonna sit here and you know
take everything seriously
right you know
i don't know even that there's like
correlation between
[ __ ] loads of homework and having a
better education you know what i mean
it's just you're already at school for
what five
six seven hours a day i mean
gotta have a [ __ ] life too even a kid
needs to have a life
yeah and then when you start getting
into ap
classes like i did because i wanted to
get into a good college you really don't
have a choice
the amount of homework you have is just
it's it's not even
that's why you just shouldn't do that
realistic just don't do it that's what i
did
you didn't i've never [ __ ] did it did
you go to college
no there you go my parents
would be so on me they wouldn't let me
do anything
i had to do all the homework study to
all the tests yeah i mean
were your parents pissed that you
weren't doing your homework yeah but
i was just i wasn't a good student i
mean i i buckled down the last couple
years of high school because i was like
on track to not graduate
yeah that's scary you don't want to do
that yeah but um yeah i [ __ ] hated
school i
hated school me too i was just not about
it
i just interesting
you're a smart guy
you're smart you're very smart yeah i
just didn't like it is a great guy
you're a great guy we all love it i like
some aspects of school you know
i i enjoyed some classes but when i came
to
if if i wasn't interested in the subject
there was no convincing me to
try i was just lunch was fun
lunch was i like the socializing aspect
of school that's true
yeah school just just know that if
you're in school and you hate it
some people like school and god bless
them you know that's the thing school
is for some people i really truly think
that the amount of homework and all this
[ __ ] needs to be re-examined
there's not a way to live your life it's
just not mm-hmm
uh ethan uh james made a statement no he
did already
in the
let's read his statement first he
already put this out damn he scared his
[ __ ] bro
there's a video going around about me on
tick talking twitter of a guy calling me
a g word not going to say it
let's say when you have good personal
hygiene
what is it called oh yeah when you have
good personal hygiene
we need to take your dog to get their
hair cut what is it called
right exactly g word and i want to
address it right away
the accusations is completely false last
week i came across someone on my insta
explorer page saw he followed me and
added him on snapchat first of all
already already you [ __ ] up
you literally are doing this all the
time yeah
i'm out you can't do that disgusting
the next morning i woke up to several
snaps from this person being excited i
added him saying he loved me
and also he sent lewd photos of himself
in the shower
i asked how old he was right away and he
told me he was 18 so i started filling
back
in the excitement of meeting someone i
thought it would be potentially great i
didn't ask for a copy of his id
now it's clear so okay first of all back
up okay i'll keep bringing we'll keep
reading
that was clear based on the video he
uploaded he was taking photos of me with
another device
and had an ulterior motive i'm sorry
you're the one that followed him
[ __ ] so how are you going to accuse
him of having an ulterior motive
when you literally did the action of
following him
wow what is he just sitting there
waiting for james charles to follow him
randomly
like dude you're a huge celebrity
there's a billion people
out there you just yeah
[ __ ] this guy dude
yeah really sad ulterior ulterior
motives
later in the day he said a few things
that made me question the
the validity of his age and when i asked
him to confirm his age once again
he admitted to being 16. so you
so right now he's admitting to
exchanging nudes
with a 16 year old oops now once again
it is not
the 16 year old yes he said flirting
back so no he said
lewds sharing lewds flirting back the
guy showed that he sent him those photos
so right away he's admitting that he
committed a crime
it is not that kid's responsibility
for you to know his age it's you that's
why you don't do these things he's
right here commit admitting to
committing a crime right here
committed a crime exchanges photos with
a 16 year old
done thing is that these allegations
already came
and bowed james you would think he would
learn i think or two
a bunch of times yeah a bunch of times
like if this
was the first time it happened to you
maybe i would understand but
this already happened
so he's go he continues i told him i was
really uncomfortable and apologized for
flirting but he insisted on continually
talking
saying could be our little secret he's a
fan of mine and would never tell anyone
i told him i wasn't okay with this
he started getting upset and at this
point i unfriended him we haven't spoken
since
i'm not victim blaming or victimizing
myself either simply sharing what
happened
okay good you've committed a crime you
would just admit it and what happened
was not okay
after false allegations like this it's
not a false elegant you literally just
admit to committing a crime
after false allegations like this in the
past i would never knowingly engage with
anyone under age
knowingly i mean what the [ __ ] bro
knowingly
what do you mean knowingly what do you
mean knowingly there's that's not an
excuse
bro he admittedly didn't ask for an idea
or anything so
what do you mean no english yeah i would
never knowingly
you know in the back of your mind you're
like this guy might not he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're a piece of [ __ ] bro stop
giving this guy a pass
[ __ ] you he says i would never knowingly
engage with anyone underage and put my
life online for a few snapchats while
you did do that
because of the situation like this
instead of taking someone's word for it
i will now ask to see the id or password
of every guy i have a conversation with
[ __ ] you
so now you learned i have to respond to
this tweet
not now
this is gonna be really quick no it's
not
because i tweeted i retweeted the
original guys has james shows blocked me
yet no
he's about to
admitting to admitting to
um committing a crime
thank you zach admitting
admitting to committing [ __ ] i can't
[ __ ] i really don't like when you tweet
on the show
exactly because of that like admitting
to committing a
crime the fresh prince of that air
king nudes people love this can you know
the world this is yours i don't know if
he said that he sent
nudes back he's yes he did he said he's
flirting back flirting back he didn't
say he said
okay correct the record [ __ ] the guy
that 16 year old showed them
you didn't say [ __ ] to me no not you i
was okay with charles james charles i
can't tell you that
hey twitter world this is yeah i'm just
making sure
calm down i would never do that jesus
scared the [ __ ] out of me
no it's the leather jacket started the
story by showing pictures of james ela
all blurred out okay yeah
so he did okay yeah admitting to
committing a crime exchange
guys
[Music]
stop giving a pass
you guys got any plans this weekend
[Music]
i don't know what the world is shut the
[ __ ] up with the chit chat man come on
stop talking a pass to this creepy
[ __ ] wavy
i said okay here it is admitting he
admitting to committing a crime
exchanging nudes with a six-year-old
with a 16 year i wrote 16 year old 16
year old i wrote it twice
can you not do it during the show
this is a serious tweet admitting to
committing a crime exchanging nudes with
a 16 year old stop giving a pass to this
predator
tweet [ __ ] you james
oh no oh no oh that was really good then
that was really good bro what is with
the
amount of people doing this like
bro this is happening so much
yo even even if you don't care about
respecting other people and doing the
right thing
at least have enough in like preserving
your own reputation and career
not to be so [ __ ] reckless and dumb
like even if you are let's say an
uncaring person you should
still know how dangerous this is for you
that's like obviously
i can't even begin hello
you're already in such a lucky position
you have all these followers
like the least you can do is start being
more responsive let's go meet someone on
twit tinder why do you have to or go out
to a club why do you have to meet people
like on snap
why do you have to meet people on
instagram dms that's just not creeping
on their social media
yeah going out of your way to add them
because you know that they're a fan
they follow you and then dudes with them
what are you doing
just don't do that and i love how he
goes charles he's like i love
i love how he goes oh he had ulterior
motives
you followed him if anything changed him
you're most made contact i can't bro i
cannot
it reminds me of the sin jared [ __ ]
where it's like oh yeah you know it's
not my responsibility even though i
created the scenario for this to happen
honestly cairo did the same [ __ ] he says
he ended up flirt well actually it
wasn't as bad because he wasn't
exchanging nudes
but he was flirting with the
six-year-old that he thought was older
but in pyro's defense he wasn't it was
there was no photos shared or anything
so it's
not as bad it was just like text
role-playing flirting stuff
but it's your responsibility to [ __ ]
know you're not talking to a child which
is the reason you shouldn't be doing
this
don't go there yeah
[Music]
um
yes yes yes let me see the comments are
people supporting him or being like
shitty go off james nobody should make
up lies like this
what's the lie a made-up part oh here's
another one y'all trying to cancel
everyone nowadays i don't get why you
think it's a good use of your time
stop trying to cancel people okay well
your your idol is literally a predator
like he's done this like
five times this month oh my god this is
the t
this way too much word girl but this
person
that's way too much words girl but all i
gotta say is jeffrey was right
tati is ice queen what are you even
speaking [ __ ] english like because
this girl must be like eight years old
tati is ice queen per has you all mad
mad
sorry
okay so somebody said this is funny i
think they're trying to support him but
actually they're exposing him they say
isn't this the third time this has
happened bestie sad face
might be a pattern okay
cool that's one of my favorite this
coffee pasta
the fact i ain't reading that i'm happy
for you though or sorry
that happened it's just like too long
didn't read you know
um the fact that he is even saying
himself
he saw this guy is following him then he
went after him
to follow him and he's like okay you are
abusing your fans predator bro
james is a predator i actually think so
oh maybe i can't say that is so true
maybe like a tiger god this episode's so
[ __ ] i just wanted to make an episode
that wouldn't go yellow now here we are
[ __ ] again james had to go and be a
predator
couldn't just take the week off from
being a predator
maybe we just need to not worry about
getting demonetized
well i'm [ __ ] anyway yeah be nice to
make a man
whatever subscribe members thank you
members
we love our members
james charles is a predator quote me on
that
yeah really sad
something is about to bust
[Music]
literally every comment is supportive
it's pretty wild yes i love how james
can actually explain the situation of
putting his feelings in it
sorry okay but where's your proof they
shared proof their farm believing the
victim oh
shout out to oh no
right shout out to violet she's right
good point
thank you for addressing this here's a
good one
thank you for addressing the situation i
knew they were a clout chaser from the
beginning
500 likes that's what that that is what
they always say
about any victim that comes out i mean
meanwhile these are the same
people right the same woke people that
go don't blame the victim
you know they are oh he's trending wow
oh [ __ ] okay
i'm a star i might really start selling
the clout pill
okay wow this is trending hang on a sec
okay so this
story the original one which i retweeted
um
that i was talking about is thirty
thousand
likes two hours why are you so active on
twitter let's get glam because it's
serious
i was like this is actually really bad i
watched it
i didn't even know you're retweeting
well i usually don't retweet things like
i'm very i'm very uh
very careful with my retweets right but
when i watched this i was like dude this
is so bad and especially considering
james charles has been accused of this
so many times
yeah and now also this guy's is the
worst i've ever seen because he has so
many pictures
and videos and everything is it's
literally like
it's not trusting him he he has it all
yeah
sister let's see
sister
sister yeah i don't know
i don't know how these guys keep getting
away what's that one they can't keep
getting away with it can you play that
please zach
i don't know i don't know if we have
that pulled though
the breaking bad clip is that what
you're talking about oh is that breaking
bad i was wondering what was the origin
of that yeah that's from breaking bad
he can't keep getting away with it oh
jesse
oh you got to grab that okay
i just saw this teacher and i was like
get triggered yeah you had really bad
you know the problem with schools is
like
in israel and also in our yeah my school
is very poor
they look like [ __ ] and um
and everything was
basically [ __ ] yeah
um
it just it doesn't appeal to high
quality people because the it just
doesn't compensate enough i mean
oh did i tell the story about how why i
didn't study physics
i know i think i told you but i don't
know if i told it on the you mean like a
podcast
yeah okay i didn't think of the class i
don't remember i found it really
interesting i really wanted you're good
at math
to go into physics class i did like math
and um and and so i took a couple of
classes like
when in the beginning of the year and
the teacher was russian
and like she barely spoke hebrew and no
one could understand anything
and physics of all things like pretty
complicated no one could understand
anything
really yeah well did you did anyone get
grades like how were they graded
i don't know a bunch of people just
didn't continue with the class and some
stayed
they literally i just didn't stay in the
class i was like i can't understand
anything that's crazy yeah you know if
you think schools are bad to hear
america the ones in israel are even
worse
teachers in israel make like 20 000 a
year
they make like almost minimum wage
so it basically appeals to rock bottom
people and in america it's not that much
better i mean
and it's no hate to russians at all i
love russians in israel
we there's a lot of them because she
just didn't
yeah there's been a lot of um
immigration from russia to israel
and it's just like a phenomenon that
it's ultimately it's just a problem of
budget you know it's not that i had a
problem with the teacher
it's just like i really couldn't
understand anything
i don't understand how education is not
more important here like
you want to know my conspiracy theory no
no yeah i do i do okay you so first of
all
dan you might know so correct me if i'm
wrong but i'm almost certain this is
true
as people become better educated
people who've gone to college the vast
majority
of those with a high and good education
become democrats or liberals is that
right dan
uh the voting demo demographics in the
united states do
lean that way yes so i do think that
conservatives have a vested interest
in keeping people uneducated and keeping
schools [ __ ]
because less educated i'm just this is
like i'm i swear to god i'm not trying
to pigeonhole you
for the world i should point out that
that that trend that you're talking
about though is more about college than
um grade school
okay but it's about college education
but it all it all leads to college right
like if you have a shitty
if you have shitty schools and
everything you don't end up going to
college and that's another reason why
they don't want free college too
because if you have free college people
go they become highly educated
and i don't i'm not saying that
education leads to liberalism okay i'm
just saying whatever happens in those
schools
i'm not trying to draw conclusions here
i don't know whatever happens in
universities
tends to lead people down a road of
liberalism
and and being more towards the
democratic party
so i do think republicans have a vested
interest in keeping people less educated
i really do i don't know about it
because i feel like it could just
be like negligent and
just like any big body like the
government
to someone there's just like so much
negligence bro they know
dude these guys know what they're doing
they know that like
the red belt all these red states
they're like on average
way less educated than the big cities
california has
one of the worst public school systems
in the country though so it's really is
that true
yes based on what right how would you
explain that oh maybe i'm wrong
yeah i didn't wait california has to
based on what what are we paying all
these taxes for for people
the school system in california are you
just saying that from your experience
are you seeing that no
no no in the rankings california's
always i know everyone's calling me a
libtard and saying i'm white
liberal trash i'm just telling you i'm
just expressing
what i've noticed okay
people want you dumb i swear to god the
government
people there's people in government that
want you [ __ ] not
getting an education people are saying
you are wrong
some people say you're right some people
say you're wrong there you go
it's typical it's an interesting
thought but i remember donald trump he
goes i love the uneducated i love the
uneducated
because uneducated people in general
lean conservative
it's just a fact it's not a statement of
the people it's just a fact somebody
look that up fact check me
come on you just say california's uh
k-12
education ranks 37th in the country why
ouch california you [ __ ]
dumbasses pretty bad what the [ __ ] why
is it so
bad we love you goddammit california i
pay so much
a lot of it is because the budgets for
the schools were gutted in the late 70s
by
uh governor ronald reagan prop 13. that
was a long time ago we haven't got our
[ __ ] together since then
nope what's prop 13. that was the big
property tax
bill that there was i forget there was
some ballot measure about it
this year or last year even to try and
uh
overturn it or something basically your
property tax gets
locked in at the rate in the year in
which you buy it and it never goes up
can never change or be reassessed that
didn't used to be the case
and most public education california is
paid for by property tax and so when
they did that
and all of the budgets tanked actually
okay
whatever now we're getting to like i
think you're getting into conspiracy
theory i just gave him my opinion look i
could be i am a i'm a libertarian
but it's true i just want to tell you
that
what you're suggesting is that they're
way more organized than they really are
in my opinion i don't think so because
that would be like an organized effort
to keep people stupid i
really don't think that i actually do
think they're that organized because
you should see what they do with
gerrymandering those [ __ ] are
scientists
they literally it's part of their
platform to
prevent people from voting to make
voting as hard as possible
and to gerrymander like a [ __ ] like
their
tetris grand masters like they are
definitely
and you know the republican party is
losing ground so they have to more and
more result to
um to tactics like gerrymandering and
voter suppression
mm-hmm but that's you can't keep getting
it
good i love it but listen i'm a libtard
you guys say what the [ __ ] you want i'm
just saying give my opinion
i'm a coastal lead i'm a rich lib
[ __ ] douche
don't take it from me just saying open
your eyes people
the truth is out there people wake up
wake up
lots of people think you're right so so
why is it
that you think the poor [ __ ] let me ask
you this why is it that you think the
poorest states almost
always like without even consideration
always go
republican always red red always always
the poorest states
with the poorer infrastructure the less
money always goes red
always even though democrats are usually
in favor
of of the kind of regulations and
changes that would most benefit them
you know part of its religion they
somehow the republicans tapped into
religion like if you don't vote
republican then you're like voting for
the devil or something yeah it's
i mean but they're in deep man they
gotta figure it out i'm telling you they
they are slick they know what they're
doing
religion their lifestyle joel biden
okay whatever i'll get off this nobody
cares you bad boy
but you know what's sad these
[ __ ] you know what one of their
tactics is
you know one of the their tactics is to
it's to make it
like like you're like a social justice
warrior or something or a libtard for
talking about these things
they discourage conversation you know
what i mean it's like a whole vibe of
like oh here we go again
we can't talk about this nobody cares oh
and how about this one
both sides are the same both sides are
the same
all politicians are trash the their
their one of their tactics is to
dissuade conversation
they don't want you to [ __ ] think
about it they want you to write off both
parties as just the same
mm-hmm
so who's ready to recount okay
[Music]
anyway you guys want me to keep going or
not
no daddy stop
[Laughter]
where's my soapbox daddy
i just i'm constantly about how do you
get poor
white working-class people to vote
against their own
interests year and year and year and
year again
that's what they do the democrats want
to expand social benefits
increase the minimum wage give help
guaranteed health care
these are the types of things that
benefit democrats don't want to give
guaranteed health care
well if there's anyone that wants to
give guaranteed health care damn they're
democrats
that's i guess you know what i'm saying
like if any if anyone's in that place
i mean obama's trying to [ __ ] do
something i mean he would get a lot more
done if they
don't i'll tell you that obama ain't
born
one of those and then who's the party of
conspiracy theories
because truth that's the whole po
okay i'm just telling you
i don't want to get taxed no
i'll tell you what once you start taxing
those billionaires
it's just one step away from taxing me
i'm paying okay i'm telling you my
freedom for the world
that papa john made a trillion dollars
selling pizza they're gonna take a bit
they're gonna take some money from him
it's just
that ain't right that's his money
those cop brothers tap that oil it's
their money
the [ __ ] brother the [ __ ] brother now
don't it don't matter that i have to
make a gofundme because my
cause my mama got cancer and i can't pay
for it
those [ __ ] brothers deserve every penny
and i'm not saying take their money
again i'm just ex
take their money fill that bag
up
i'm just saying that there are forces in
this country that want you
dumb and poor and confused
all right do that back up they got
people so
[ __ ] confused they don't know their
ass from a hole in the wall
they don't know the [ __ ] it is they
don't the [ __ ]
they don't people don't even understand
progressive tax rates
they think taxing the [ __ ] brothers
by the way there is going to increase
their time do you know what
progressive tax rate is your ass doesn't
get
taxed it's just the rich [ __ ] i'll pay
more taxes i'll give a [ __ ] but i'm not
even
i'm rich but i'm not [ __ ] brother rich
you know i mean i'm not elon musk jeff
bezos is rich
go ahead yolo whatever i'm not done i'll
go on and on
they call them i was just gonna say um
that
you just reminded me something my sister
told me in israel
they're trying to get everyone to
vaccine because uh they got
the vaccines and people they got the
same like conspiracy theory that
they're just they're just doing the
testing on us and we're in
their lab so people don't want to do it
and um
she told me some people will go as far
as like
schedule an appointment and then not
show up so that they
waste the vaccine oh my god that should
be prison
yeah how can you 19. yeah i mean
listen
people don't what can you do i mean the
collapse of society
is is upon us when people trust
facebook posts more than than
scientist the scientific community yeah
but that's what they
when you're so [ __ ] i mean you have
doctors telling you they think it's
actually a really good vaccine
they're really happy with it forget that
there's they've been
they've been doing laboratory tests on
millions of people
across tons of countries in controlled
conditions
as good as any other vaccine we've done
by the way when you have people that
[ __ ] confused about something that's
so
verifiably you know inarguably true
you can convince them of any [ __ ]
stupid thing they call them dumps
you know
so people still think trump won the
election
you know it's like that's how it works
if you could convince people of
ethan whoa
that freaked me out this election wait
why did he say ethan what was that
zach's got one for like everybody on the
crew that's that just scared me i was
like that new
did we always have that i didn't know i
don't know if we've ever used the
ethanol
he uses the one of him saying thank you
damn yeah that one we love
there's an e in one too right there
there is an ian one yeah
cool yeah and you know okay cool yeah
and you know like
please stand up go ahead dan stand up
ian ian stand up the president's talking
yeah
dan stand up stand up the president
commands it
[Laughter]
you know all right come up thank you
thank you
well done sir how is the jungle coming
together
i'm really curious what's going on there
i like the monkey on the lamp you got
there
[Applause]
the jungle has been at the beginning oh
that
yeah by the way i encourage you guys to
go check out our episode from yesterday
we put on this high fashion show that
was one of the best
segments we've done in a long time i
mean the amount of work and effort
these guys put into making that grade is
staggering and amazing do it after this
though don't close this obviously
obviously what was the name of that um
that marketing company that like
basically hacked facebook for data and
the
last election something oh geez what the
[ __ ] were they called uh
i don't remember something republica
something
no anyway you guys all i'm sure you guys
most you guys heard about this story
why are we talking about this now
cambridge analytica yeah cambridge
analytica
they literally hacked into [ __ ]
facebook
to campaign for trump and they ran
fake [ __ ] ads lies and fake ads to
confuse people
that is their [ __ ] strategy they want
you confused
they want you [ __ ] dumb they want you
angry a [ __ ] that literally never even
happened
right
when you can't distinguish fact from
[ __ ] fiction on something so as
important as a vaccine we're doomed okay
next story you
bad boy thank you oh god forbid i try to
talk about something that's important to
me without being a social justice
warrior
that's what they want you to think
[Music]
oh jesus scares me okay
[Applause]
um the sia movie that's the sea movie
man
i don't know what to say about this you
guys heard about the see a movie
so sia the art the musician made a film
about a girl with a younger sister who
has autism
but it's getting widely criticized
for depicting the autistic sister
as as a a simple jack type of character
from tropic thunder you remember that he
portrayed like a really offensive
over-the-top portrayal of somebody with
a mental uh
disability and it currently has an 11 on
rotten tomatoes
11 out of 100 yeah 11 11 people said
awful and offensive i heard one of the
critics say it's just plain awful and
offensive
there's one point one point yeah i know
what and apparently she's been like five
years on it did the whole soundtrack
she really thought she was doing
something good yeah
i don't know so i watched the trailer
and i thought
i was like this could be okay but
there's a few
shots where the with the autistic sister
and you can tell like oh
like it reminds me of the brother from
something about mary like she's
literally doing an impression of that
okay let me find the scenes of
i'm just gonna mute it here's here's the
sister look with the headphones
she's literally doing this
and she's supposed to be what autistic
yeah
yeah that's not i mean i'm no there's
people with like really severe autism
that obviously is really debilitating
but
yeah but i don't know anything one with
autistics but everyone who's like an
autistic advocate said this
is like super offensive well i watched
we watched the finding love
here she is here she is she's walking
like a spectrum
oh yeah yeah they're not like this yeah
they're not like this at all and those
people actually have
in some cases really severe autism here
she is walking literally like the
brother from something about mary and
i'm gonna find a clip look at her
let me find something about mary brother
and we should say
a big part of the criticism is that the
actress portraying this character is not
autistic
right like there's lots of autistic
people who could have uh
all right this is funny you've got the
headphones
yeah exactly hi ted it's [ __ ] awesome
so and then there's another thing which
she did so
at one point in the film and again i'm
not familiar with any of this i'm just
reading
apparently um there used to be this
thing called prone restraint
that people did when people were having
autistic
outbreaks where it's when you lay on
them here maybe
i can show a picture of it there's a
there's actually i put in a clip
from the movie of that scene of it
happening i don't know if i can can i
show it is it like really violent
um no it's not really violent
i'll just show it still of it oh this is
it
okay yeah okay so
so here it is so she's having a uh
episode and
apparently so they go oh i know what to
do
i'm gonna restrain her so she lays on
top of her
and holds her down basically oh that was
really short so anyway it turns out that
what she did is actually super dangerous
and has led to uh deaths and serious
injury
and it's not recommended like it's
highly unrecommended
wait what the prone restraint when
somebody's having an episode
uh to just grab them and restrain them
like
how did they not get all this stuff
that's the thing
she spent five years making this movie
and supposedly deeply researching it and
there's just all this [ __ ] in it that's
like
seems like they didn't really do any
research at all
weird but there's like really big actors
in it which is kind of more confounding
um one of the actors from hamilton by
the way but it's like a musical
and anyway she has spent five years
making this apparently
um the movie got nominated for two
golden globes apparently the
the the golden globes uh sent those
nominations before the reviewers had a
chance to see it
it just goes to show what [ __ ] it is
golden globes are trash
she and response deleted her twitter and
shame
so i feel i do find feel bad for her
because she puts so much time into it
it's pretty brutal and she's just half a
decade maybe i have a feeling that
you know her intention must have been oh
yeah oh for sure
but i don't know how did they miss so
bad that's
i kind of almost don't blame her i feel
like somebody well
i feel like somebody with some level of
expertise should have been involved in
the making that film
but it is being presented as her project
right like
that's what i keep here yeah yeah
directed it she wrote it she made it
for a studio or there's an executive
producer or somebody
with experience it's like we're making a
vid we were making a movie about
autism let's make sure that it's
accurate yeah
yay so shout out to csf and her family
man let me check on the james charles
situation
he can't keep getting away with it he's
literally never going to stop messaging
young
boys james charles can't keep getting
away with this
um he will never stop i do
wonder in this case like why they didn't
look for an autistic person to play the
role because
after watching love on the spectrum i
just feel like
it was absolutely good it was such a
good insight into
what this this girl would have been
really interested in is her muse
this is the girl if you remember from
the uh
all of her music videos uh the same
actress oh that was the little girl who
was dancing girl yes
she was on that show dance mom but like
didn't we establish
long ago that like having somebody
who like you can't go full and
sorry if this is offensive but in the
words of tropic thunder
you can't go full [ __ ] like you can't
you have to you can't do that anymore
like that's not okay
then again i'm that's offensive language
that's what tropic thunder said
about the simple jack characters is what
they're accusing her of doing
like you have to get somebody who
understands the situation to play it
right right you're right
right all right man did you want to talk
about
um trisha are you saving it for monday
oh what was the issue with trisha
the port 9 thing oh the pork boy pork
boys
oh [ __ ] that guy he's such a douche i
knew pork boy was a douche
yeah i'd love to talk about i want to
talk about with her monday too but
where's the pork
oh she did good [ __ ] pork boy here let's
watch your videos
give my girl trisha pork night
pork night
let's see what trish had to say because
she'll probably oh thank you ian
barstow pirating my nudes i don't think
i love that that's her takeaway like
that wasn't what i thought
like her she originally responded and
and she was like
excuse me you owe me money for everybody
who watched it
and i was like i'm actually just
offended that's funny she's just funny
and
of course she's wearing all decked out
and adam sandler gear daddy
so i just got a tweet
from god she has the best youtube she
has the best content
in the game i cannot i just can't dude
she has
the best content wow thank you
what's up how are you couldn't you like
set the camera up before you started
recording you know but only trish you
could pull it off like
set it up and then hit record
it's always got to be like this i guess
it's part of the
it is charged i agree i would never
think to do that though you know what i
mean yeah
that's interesting trash
that's
i never condone rape but if you're a
size six and you're wearing skinny jeans
oh we can't show this you kind of
wait what are we watching i can't say
the r word
anyway look give me the original video
somebody somebody like
no this is trisha i want you i mean what
happened
yeah the tweet here it is
so they pull up her only fans and he
films everyone laughing
and being disgusted and gagging stuff
oh my god don't throw up on me
why is he gagging to be fair i've done
this to her
nudes okay that being said it doesn't
make much sense that they would go out
of their specific way to post like
that's weird right
and i mean she was just on their podcast
she was really nice to go on their
podcast and she got them a ton of views
and they were mean to her on the podcast
and now they're just going to like
post themselves gagging and being all
grossed out by her nudes
i mean the main thing
no one is wearing a mask oh my gosh and
all of barstool sports office what is
this
these people are huddle around masculine
it's like trust me
you all [ __ ] thought i was playing
when i said dave portnoy's a douche he's
a
[ __ ] dangerous douchebag like this is
your office culture
you can't do that you just can't
has anyone actually died good question
trish i'm sure she'll have a lot to say
about on monday but
like i mean again i've made fun of her
nudes being gross or whatever not my not
my cup of tea but
i feel like that we have a rapport where
the honest sounds is different though
because
from what i understand they were just
watching her home tour
naked yeah would you like gagging i
can't imagine what would make you gag
but
okay i haven't seen it so whatever well
why would they just
grow yeah like why would you post it i
don't know
i don't know yeah it's icky gross and no
math
girls yeah what the [ __ ] and like what
the [ __ ] is and then they erased it by
the way
but how is it how did you make it about
pirating my news
like that's the least troubling thing
about this video
is that they pirated it how did you even
know they pirated it well because one
person is showing it to the office
he just wants licenses from everyone
involved
is it ap because he's an idiot okay
we're not even talking about a.b
trish i get it though this is trisha's
net worth i'm interesting four million
what are you looking at it just auto
completed it
i don't know what she's worth just
google that stuff is not even accurate
no i know anyways whatever
it was the top finished question trisha
paytas net worth
he had sent me something oh i'll ignore
that wrong link wrong link okay
uh someone posted on the subreddit that
they dm'd little tracy
and asked him if he wants to call in and
he said i want to
he does oh is he available right now a
little trace
we can we can try we can get little
tracy on the [ __ ] phone
yo he's gonna be so mad we have to be
careful it might be risky live
oh you think so yeah he might be a
little loose cannon saying a lot of
obscenities and stuff
but isn't that exciting to hear what he
has to say
i don't believe that he really doesn't
like us i think it's a gag
yeah someone said h3 said they want your
want you to be your friend i want you to
call to their show they're on stream
right now
he says i want to call in
i feel like it's only fun if it's live
if it's pre-recorded then who cares
yeah can you have a bleep button where
you can
we don't have a kill switch or something
damn it
it's exciting thought though but you
could mute
you could just mute the podcast i guess
only after the fact though
yeah i don't think there's any way to
prevent i'm just afraid he's gonna come
out with like n bombs
wait even live right now you can't mute
the whole like if i'm talking you can't
mute me
well i can but i can't anticipate that
you're suddenly yeah if he's
oh yeah it would be in reaction yeah it
wouldn't be immediate it's too late
though that's what i'm saying
at that point it's too late if it goes
out well if we can get him on
then let's do
if we can get them on ian then then i'll
take the call
i'll take the call are you working on it
ian
yeah interesting
well i don't know anything about lil
tracy other than that he hates
us what is there anything i should know
about lil tracy before we get on a call
with him
oh okay right right i think he's
good like silly i really think
we got the wrong idea here i'm not too
worried
it's just live that's all but hey i'm
ready to be a little tracy fan
the funny thing about him is that he
keeps changing his name on twitter
like i can't even find him right now
because i follow him but i can't even
find it the screenshot i saw he set his
twitter to private
when he said h3 keep my name out of your
mouth it was a private tweet which means
only people who follow him can see it
it's exciting
what else we got zach schneider
[Music]
bro you guys got so angry last time i
made fun of the jacks
the zack schneider's justice league it's
one of our most disliked highlights ever
yep did someone like me that highlight
uh yeah but anyway the reason i bring up
the zac
snyder justice league
is because apparently the
jared leto joker is getting a huge
feature in it
so like somehow they didn't get the memo
that everybody hates jared leto joker
here let's see i was blown away you know
let's see justice league we're saying
there's no way this movie is going to be
good
trailer look at the dislikes you guys
ever seen anything like that in your
life
wow we said there's no way yeah i was
just searching for it
and uh there's other videos uh h3h3's
terrible reaction video to zack snyder
oh really
there's like content about our take yes
how many views does that one have
not a lot 50 000. dude 50 000 views
five thousand dislikes oh the name is
pretty the name is pretty inflammatory
almost
the name of the clip is justice league
is try hard garbage
that's a little bit tough wait so let's
read the comments i'm scared
how can you polish a turd a perfect way
to describe this channel
oh turned it around everybody keeps
making about his daughter it's very sad
that his daughter died it doesn't make
me
good to be fair to be fair i wish you
told me about his daughter
before i made this [ __ ] like blast
off video because
i feel like i had no idea about the
story with his daughter
and it just made me look kind of
insensitive huh
so i blame dan kind of for that all
right blame me
i don't think it it doesn't impact the
quality of the fact i agree with you but
i'm just saying like here's the second
government zack snyder's daughter
committed
s word during movies production and he
had to leave so i was like okay yeah
ethan's an [ __ ]
i hope dan is going to be okay
[Laughter]
here someone says you literally have no
idea what you're talking about i mean
name a good movie he's made except 100.
a third of the credit here wait what the
movie is 300 not 100 wow
exactly you're talking about 300
yeah 100 [ __ ]
most annoying video i've ever seen jesus
these people sound like old people who
hate technologies
i'm sorry you know his movies suck his
movies [ __ ]
suck like they look cool like i would
say
don't even look cool that's not true
washed out garbage
terrible cinematography awful films
front to back nothing redeeming
i disagree i think they look cool like
watchmen i want i wanted to like that
so much you know what i mean like i
wanted to like it so much
it was okay not the show there was a
movie he made
ethan making fun of the song not knowing
zack chose it because his dead
daughter's favorite song that's your
fault dan
yeah that's not fair that's your [ __ ]
fault you did that
well someone said ethan hasn't seen the
movie how can you say polish a turd i've
seen the movie isn't it just a recut of
the movie that exists
it's it it's more significant than that
for all intents and purposes it is a
different film so we don't know what
we're talking about oh so we didn't know
we're talking about that
it's not that doesn't mean that
it dan did it this is dan's fault
so anyway here's the tree alert that
everyone was freaking out
because joker jared letter joko
literally says we live in a society
that might be the wrong link because
there's one that well
oh this is well i'm kind of curious but
jared let us says we live in a society
like okay dude whatever you're [ __ ]
in a cold
hey everyone i'm excited to show you the
first official trailer
for zack snyder's justice league check
it out who's this is this him yes
so why does he say why does he say my he
says zack snyder is cut it's like
what are you talking in third person
third person a lot he does
he does that everything all the
marketing for this is like
presented by zack snyder zack snyder's
cut of the zack snyder cut of
zack center's justice league
christian got his name on it like 20
times guys please don't hate me for not
liking this trailer oh my god just
please don't kill me
i'll try to be more factual though all
right then go easy
lay down dan i'm gonna try to um be as
fair as possible though
[Music]
okay
well did he make the superman film yes
okay so first of all i have to tell you
guys with peace and love one of the
worst movies i've made right i love
superman and when i saw that trailer i
was
wanted to like that movie so bad you
remember i even looked at you and i was
like oh this is gonna be so good i'm so
excited
i'm telling you guys you cannot put back
the piece of my heart that was torn out
from how
[ __ ] dog [ __ ] this superman film was
it was without a doubt one of the worst
most offensive
horribly made horribly conceived movies
i've ever seen
and to and you have superman which is
some of the best lore
you could have made it so good and it
was just the biggest
[ __ ] heaping pile of [ __ ] i hate that
movie you cannot disagree
that movie was so bad people love it
they defend it no no no
no nobody likes that no
that are downloading our video it's the
same people well not that he's
just i think people were mad about the
whole daughter issue that i was ignorant
no you
you don't understand hold on hold on
what's the name of that movie superman
man of steel
man and i was like oh man of steel it's
gonna be so good that was so bad
i thought it was so good
met 2013 sounds about right
okay wait i'm looking at the imdb it has
a seven no i can't deal with that
this is not called dude that movie was
so bad you guys i almost
walked down black hole raging confusion
it has a 53 on meta which i guess is
better but
probably too generous you guys you can't
like this film
i almost it was so stupid literally
oh you guys stop please okay and then he
of course also made batman vs superman
which is even worse somehow
significantly worse
which is crazy because like i felt like
they were perfectly cast i was like he's
a great superman
ben affleck's a great batman and somehow
it was dog doo doo
burning dog doo doo doo any guys like
this admit it zack admit it a b
admit it i never saw it
i didn't like it no i didn't like it
you're just saying that
no no i i kind of hit my mute i didn't
like it okay
i was expecting
i wanted a backstory that was
interesting and about someone who was
vulnerable and gritty and dark
i didn't get that totally what we were
expecting too
love any comment haven't seen it
okay god bless you look what time is it
there love love's in sweden
peace and love peace and love
so soon midnight almost midnight yep
that's not too bad
[Music]
[Music]
the music is such an easy mode because
it's like such an easy way to invoke
emotion
it's like a jealous thing cube
well we have to watch it you know for
the man for sure
maybe it's good i don't know [ __ ] me
maybe it's good
i love superheroes i'll watch it with an
open mind my prediction is it's going to
be one of the worst films i've ever made
guys i
want it to be good just because i want
it so bad to be i want all these films
to be good i love these superheroes i
love batman i love superman i want this
i had a dream i'm sorry the
cinematography that's just like
yellow everything yeah this yellow
everything it's not like
there was a moment when like there was
blue everything
and i hated all those movies now it's
yellow it kind of lies at the
convergence of those two things because
i hate that because he has the the
everything's blue thing going on
that's like an immediate bad movie
to defend ourselves
how do you know your team's strong
enough i mean you can't really tell
anything from the trailer to be honest
because they
they managed to make like superman look
good in the trailer
and it was the weirdest it was also like
the weirdest
film the editing in man of steel is some
of the worst i've ever seen in a movie
whoa whoa whoa
zach oh my god [ __ ]
exactly what happened where's jared leto
he why is j why is it it's coming up
the joke one thing that is joker even in
this film
why is joker in this film
apparently he wasn't originally they
they've consciously gone out of their
way to shoot new material which
why the [ __ ] is joker in this
film do you understand what i'm saying i
mean he is a
the iconic villain for batman so it how
is
joker going to save the planet
joker brain yeah he's like joker's good
at causing mayhem
and chaos how is he going to save the
[ __ ] planet
it's joking brain
i gotta see this joker clip bro it's
coming up
you're sitting here for a reason
[Music]
also batman's not supposed to use
weapons and he was like shooting guns
wait was that ben
affleck's back yeah i think that was uh
no i think that was a caval that's bad
that was superman
that's that's that's uh that's batman
once again shooting projectiles oh no
that's superman
yeah superman okay yeah come on ela just
wanted to see our favorite tattoo yo
he literally was sniping people in one
of these films and anyone that knows
anything about batman he doesn't use
[ __ ] weapons superman
and also kills in cold blood in these
movies he doesn't have an understanding
of these characters
every trailer wait um
[Music]
dude i'm still waiting for how joker is
involved in this [ __ ] story
[Applause]
zach if you claim me i'm gonna kill you
peace and love i'm not gonna kill anyone
[Music]
worst joke wait
so they did like a whole big joker
moment we live
in a society where honor
is a distant memory isn't that right
[Music]
batman
[Applause]
the timing on that lap exactly that's
fantastic
this i mark my words let's watch it i
really want to watch
march 18th make fun of all right but if
anything proves to me beyond a shadow of
a doubt
that this movie is gonna suck bad that
last joker scene
we living in society i'm [ __ ] stoked
i'm excited to see it too but oh march
18 that's really soon
that's really soon okay you guys gonna
laugh at my
face and call me an idiot
dude hbo max is like coming hard was
perfect
yeah it's um i'm going to watch it with
an open mind me too despite all the [ __ ]
if it's if it's good i'm happy to admit
that i'm ready
do a
schneider and his 100 troopers that
could never be taken down
i'm really excited are you doing that
intentionally
that time i did intentionally well live
in a society
[Applause]
you guys come on though you know zach
originally uh called me to be in the
movie
um he's trying to recast jared yeah
right i did i had worked that day so i
couldn't
you had to work on the h3 podcast you
were exactly exact ladies and gentlemen
give it up for zach i love it
just to prove my loyalty to you guys
thank you
well what did we think about the recent
joker movie
we loved it yeah guess who was not
involved in it in any way
schneider or his [ __ ] joker
you guys want to do a joke or tier list
is that a [ __ ] now might be a fun time
how long we've been going dan
uh i've actually been going pretty long
we are
two hours 15 minutes ish you want to end
off with the joker tier list
yeah i know this is dumb but i thought
it'd be funny with zach's obsession and
jared leto we've been talking a lot
about different jokers how do i do this
though because then you have to open
it and uh it's in photoshop i already i
pre-opened it on your screen
what exactly or ian got going on over
here oh
what is it interesting you've got this
is a collage oh this is all this action
get away let me see everything behind
you and you can narrate for us go ahead
i'm just still writing on the wall here
pretty much
so this movie is gonna [ __ ] kick out
i love that aquaman was the only one
how did you do this so fast what's going
on here
i just screenshot them aquaman yeah
they're not all zack snyder but it's all
in the same
he's sort of the the visionary of the
overall uh
series how interesting like aquaman's
the least the one that i would least
expect to like do half well that was the
only one that just kind of
it was a little bit self-aware of the
fact that aquaman is goofy and just kind
of leaned into it
i watched aquaman on a film or on
flight it was pretty did you like it i'm
sorry it was pretty dog
okay fair enough sorry i mean it was
okay get your word straight jack
but y'all really forgetting about
suicide squad suicide squad
uh this new um wonder woman by the way
oh we have a
yeah no yeah i heard it was really bad
just i i
admit i i have not seen it but uh i
the reviews i was reading it sounded
pretty shocking how terrible it is well
you know i loved the first one the first
one i thought was great
yeah i think uh a lot of people like
that first one but
was zach involved in the first one i
think he's an executive producer on all
of them because
again they kind of gave him the reins to
this whole uh
extended universe of movies so where's
the tier list i don't have it on my
computer where is it
photoshop should already be open it's
been last
i don't believe you go ahead i'm gonna
hack your computer right now go ahead
i mean i even clicked it and it said i
need to enter my
my id oh [ __ ] did it get logged out okay
i'm sorry for doubting you give me a
second
[Music]
i'll definitely come out here and just
each crow on this zack schneider [ __ ]
i promise you just please don't
like swap me or something because i
didn't like the trailer
oh okay dan's logging in thank you
confirm your phone number exciting stuff
yeah exciting stuff here
[Music]
dan is confirming his phone number uh
two-step
adobe
[Music]
okay waiting dan is waiting for his text
this is
another segment
hey dan that's not bad huh
we are waiting we are waiting we are
waiting dan is a great guy dan
he is verifying the number now
that's one day and has been fantastic
that's two digits he's having trouble
typing the number in ian is there any
maybe um donation dan is well i don't
know what's going on with dan typing in
this code but he's going back to the
first one erasing it
intriguing okay we invalid code
trying a diff totally different code
that one was successful
go ahead enter his password we are
logging into adobe
excellent we we we've landed we've
arrived wake up
so we have to sign out of the device a
couple donations
uh yeah rory donated and said mark
hamill better be at the top of your
joker to your list
for sure
[Music]
for sure uh let's see thank you
superman's
superman's photoshopped uh mustache and
man of steel is unacceptable
no that wasn't that was in justice
league wasn't it
yeah i think it or well either way it's
like wherever it was that was
it so here's what they did if you guys
don't know
he he had a mustache because he was
doing another movie for
during reshoots and so they're like it's
fine we'll just photo we'll just
digitally remove the mustache or add it
or digitally add it i think they removed
it yeah
look at this oh my god no
and that's pictures of him like on set
what he actually looked like i
know so you know look at this
nope
nope wow something but that is a bra
moment right there
oh geez okay you guys ready
ready okay this is exciting joke our
tier list in honor of zack
and zach schneider let's see we've got
zach
let's start with zach's on here i mean
so let's start with um
jared leto which is obviously going to
be f just to set our baselines you know
yeah yeah and then our favorite joker
so we have toys wait where is wait you
guys don't have mark oh we do it yeah we
do
so mark hamill so here let's get the
good ones out and then think
the new one
you got to put my jack jack like these
are all kind of
these are the iconic jokers this is
going to be actually a tough call for me
[Music]
i personally would put the mark hamill
one
top tier that's s that's that's my vote
i he's so good
you know i had no [ __ ] idea that was
mark hamill like until
maybe like a few years ago and i watched
the batman show my whole life
and he's so [ __ ] he's such a talented
voice actor
yep he's also great with batman video
games
i feel like all the good ones are s yeah
i feel like honestly
these are all s peace and love jack
nelkisson's was great for the time but
it wasn't as
like a serious i mean he definitely
deserves an a
i'd agree like a tier lower is fair yeah
lego so i i'm actually not familiar with
lego
uh i can't voice by zach galifianakis
really yeah i've never watched it
i honestly can't comment so i'll just
put him c
seems pretty fair well what do you think
have you seen the movie zach
uh yeah i mean i've seen everything
related to joker joker brain
joker lore ian do me a favor will you
catch will you read a review
of um zach gal finesse finance
joker from lego movies who's that
zach galifianakis his joker
come on man so we'll let's see what the
critics had to say about it
now what how were we placing zach
i'd say like d or e tier i'll [ __ ] you
damn
yeah i'll put you above jared
you're gonna you're you're gonna do me
like that what do you want what
i'm gonna lie and just be you know give
you this where do you see your friend's
favor
yeah i'm [ __ ] eighth here dude at
least
you're on the same you're on the same
level as jack nicholson bro
i live this life back you're wearing a
joker max from target bro
no i'm not from target it's from amazon
thank you very much it's worse
you can uh here's a review of zach's
galvanicus's joker
he said his gleeful kid-friendly joker
was just as adorable as he was crazy
probably the least intimidating version
you will ever see
sounds like an egg shot
oh he is outshined by his on-screen
batman who is much funnier
oh is that you get upstage right yeah
like a d
that sounds like a d to me
hey people really like that huh
apparently lego got like a whole dynasty
that i'm not aware of like the games
movies people really love these legos
yeah these legos i haven't seen the one
the joker one but that original lego
movie was fantastic
so zach with peace and love i mean let's
just be honest bro you're no zach
nobody you're on your own you're on your
league of your own but that's [ __ ] up
man
you know you want a f yeah
can you put me at least a b i mean look
at that
there's no [ __ ] look at my toys
you know i'm you're poised no i don't
think the joker
you're awesome bro i'm putting you here
where you could just barely see the
image
give me dirty dude why didn't you look
like zach who is this
uh his name is cameron uh
i can't pronounce his last name but i
swear to god i thought that was you zack
nah he's on the show gotham and he was
also uh
i guess he would know him from the show
shameless gotham that doesn't sound very
promising can you give me a review
please ian
of his joker's stick one second
meanwhile creed you know is asked here
over [ __ ] oh my god look at that that
is i have never seen falloff joker like
creed is right here right now
in fact creed should be the only one in
s tier and i should move all these down
a little bit this is rigged
creed is asked here only
i would be most terrified of him
i mean i don't know what to say this is
like the og joker like
i have no comment he was the goat dude i
think
i think he is pretty iconic i think at
least on the same tier as jack
bailey okay there you go i'll give him
respect i mean that old show is goofy as
hell but
uh but he was great that creed
that [ __ ] creed joker shot is iconic
you cannot convince me that this is the
greatest thing ever
yeah that's asked here for sure wait
didn't we
i thought i thought ab had a joker pick
too
well if he does but his was the uh his
is down here with zach wherever it is
the jared leto uh joker remember so get
you got it you got a review for me again
so where we know where to place uh the
gotham joker uh yeah it says
uh that he has the mischievous grin down
but there are too many moments of is he
the joker or not because he has a twin
brother
he might be the joker this is the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you yeah grinning and twin this was
the joker of a twin
uh someone's saying we're forgetting
tuna's joker
oh how could we forget
dan you see him doing it you don't have
the [ __ ] baby okay guys
that go ahead no you're going i'm
talking now just do it you're in my
computer no
you don't know where to go ahead dan
hacks into my [ __ ] computer yeah i am
doesn't take a rocket surgeon ethan
okay dan so fast he goes save image
save the desktop wow this is genius who
could have ever figured this out
go ahead i'm watching i'm watching
that was high level [ __ ] bro it's not
working
and it's not it's not even worth it's
not working
uh i think you gotta put it up on the
layers genius all right it's it's hard
for me to do this remote
i apologize you can go ahead and handle
it oh thank you dick
oh see i fixed it did work no i figured
i've actually got gotten better at first
joker okay
in the past in the past that you've been
intimidated by it so thank you
we go well you know he's asked because
he's the most terrifying along with
creed
yeah like he's [ __ ] me what what's
your argument against that all right
zach give us a joker impression oh no
okay all right let me pull you out of
the void zach and see
let's put you up this is your big moment
you're out of the void for now
what's a classic one a little more a
little more what's a classic line he
could do
put a smile on that face put a smile on
that face that's a good one
that's like keith ledger joker what does
it matter
what you that's a joker line they're
aiming for the stars
there's different jokers so which joker
are you bro i'm not
which joker are you zack all right zach
okay give me a line it's falling down
back to the void
i eat [ __ ] mayonnaise that should be
enough
how do you know that's not mayonnaise on
my face that white makeup how do you
know it's not male you at one point
promised you'd do that and you never
came through
what the [ __ ] are you talking about i
did that on the christmas special yeah
yeah you know i i gotta jump in and and
defend my guy zach here really yeah i
think
i think he's j-tier
[Music]
ian my man isn't that where he is do you
want him just off
the screen totally down here right there
go to my screen please
but it's not showing yeah i'm slowly
going down
all the way to the void here's his photo
yeah i mean jt is fine
down here h i down here jay
thank you nice and love thanks ian
all right this is a pretty definitive
list
off the charts but always
that's good all right guys what else is
there to say
nada nada that's it
no word on lil tracy i don't think it's
gonna happen
no response from tracy of course
don't say anything bad about him don't
say anything bad about him no i don't
want to i don't want to throw a little
trace
we are cool with little tracy is he the
guy with the diamond in his forehead
no
okay well we're done so if you guys want
to watch so teddyfresh.com lots of cool
stuff go check it out
if you want to keep watching hd podcast
over the weekend check out our last
episode that came out yesterday it's
phenomenal
and until then we look forward to
tuesday you know we're going to have a
good episode on thursday
that's right and actually i don't want
to ruin anything but we have huge
costume vibes on tuesday too
yes all right you do it yeah don't spill
it
a huge costume vibe i can't wait
that's fun well thank you guys
thank you thank you with peace and love
and love i
appreciate you guys i love you all thank
you to the members who
come here and support us graciously yes
it makes such a difference thank you
thank you for joining
you get all the episodes as soon as we
possibly can
peace and love peace love
love love we gotta go cruising the new
car
we got to go out
we gotta go doing some prep for the
costume today right
that's right yes i am the work party
starts tonight
i can't believe it all right gamers
[Music]
i'm in the nightmare frontier slash and
the nightmare of
the shin or whatever his name is
oh the nightmare frontier is that place
optional or what because i cleared it
all and just went to a dead end
um i think the frontier is
optional okay the other guy's nightmare
like
the frenzy is insane like i immediately
died so i had to like
i didn't understand what was going on i
was like just all of a sudden dying so i
had to go
but now i'm good i got like the frenzy
jam and the friendly clothing and stuff
and now i'm better
[ __ ] yeah but the guys that are so
strong it's
crazy it's pretty much the end of the
game you're almost there oh am i
yeah wow i didn't that's one of the
shortest
blood games i've played if that's the
case but the last few bosses i've you
haven't done any of the dlc yet though
have you
no no none of that go do that before you
beat the game really
yeah i don't understand dlcs you do
before the game ends that doesn't make
sense it's supposed to add
because everybody already beat the game
when the dlc comes out
uh true but in their case it just gets
kind of inserted
into the middle so you think it makes
more sense to beat the dlc before the
end of the game
i do and sh and should i do that at this
point in the game or should i wait
i think you're ready ela
that's so [ __ ] over it all right
black was fun i'm just glad surprisingly
short broccoli soup take talk
okay right chocolate soup go to my tick
tock i want to make broccoli soup for
y'all
you know bloodborne was probably the
most fun i had but i found it to be the
easiest and shortest of the
series i think it's just that you've
played them all so much that you're
really good now and you're able to just
blast the room
that's awesome i feel like such a
[ __ ] pro now because last time i
played bloodborne i quit out of pure
you're like halfway off the screen now i
quit out of pure frustration i feel like
this is impossible to be
i i think this whole thing started with
you yelling at me and having an argument
on the show about how
these games [ __ ] suck right it was so
boring it's over the show's over of
course we're losing thanks got it
imagine how many people are gonna lose
when we end the stream daddy
daddy the real foot soldiers will stick
around till next week just stay
right on this page karamari is the best
game if you guys
yeah i'm not gonna
[Music]
honestly i tried the jigsaw thing but i
can't i can't give up the holy sword
it's just
the damage is so insane fair enough i
don't know you know
yeah i get it i can't believe the game's
almost over so fast you know the last
boss i played
i literally i'm one shotting bosses now
dan first try bosses you well you farmed
up
if you i mean if you want a real
challenge do a soul level one
um you know no leveling i don't want a
real challenge
is new game plus worth it on bloodborne
is there another game like katamari that
anyone can recommend
well there's there's a few katamari
games there's not just one
i don't know if you've played them all
uh i've probably played them all wait
dan is new game plus good on bloodborne
um i don't think it really has anything
special about it
it's just a harder challenge yeah you
guys have any game
go ahead uh tracy has not responded
to our message from the podcast uh
instagram
but he just wrote a flame emoji on one
of my pictures
my account oh what was the picture send
me the link i want to see what he liked
wait is it with your costume with the
pyramid i knew it
see i think we could be good friends you
think we could i really
yeah does anyone call him trace
you you do now call me trace
that's awesome that you guys are dogs
now yeah
i don't even know how he ended up there
how he found you
give me the link let's check in
little trace is snooping on your [ __ ] do
you follow him
no oh my goodness you better follow him
back oh yeah where is he because i only
follow him on twitter
bro hit me with that waiting music zack
oh there it is
i'm gonna like it why is it taking so
long to give me a link
[Music]
peace and love i followed him i'm
waiting for the link to
into ian's instagram where the flame is
okay
are you sending me a screenshot okay
[Music]
okay yeah well this photo is [ __ ]
epic yeah
yeah did you photoshop that or was that
like cam grants
uh i did it last night dude
he's blasting off love me daddy this is
a sick post bro
blocking the bad vibes thank you
wow so confused how he ended up there i
i just don't know
surely he doesn't understand the context
or anything too he's like this photo is
[ __ ] dope and he's right
nice good posting and i'm gonna go like
that i didn't see why does it never show
up on my feet i'm gonna go like ian's
pose
i like ian's instagram
because he's so private and i am
starving
so i just want to know if the show is
old yeah what the [ __ ] in your posts are
so good here's one of you with the lady
gaga oreos hella funny
did you make this too oh yeah yeah
jeez you work oh oh my god you got some
great photos here
give him give me ian that all right have
a good weekend everybody
obviously
[Applause]
love y'all peace and blessings upon you
right joel austin if you are happy to be
a celebrity or anyone with a following
listen to this
do not flirt with your fans in the dm's
meet them in other ways
all right or actually you know what i
mean i'm even going to put another
footnote
people don't have the final sign and
some of the doors
oh we already heard that well i was like
well joel we can all look back
and see times when we gave into
temptation
we literally talking about temptation we
were sloppy
and didn't handle the situation the way
we should he is speaking directly to you
shut up joel i'm trying to make a point
okay i'm not going to talk about the
text now you already convinced me
how do you get the divorce doesn't know
how to stop it
just turn it off goodbye i was saying if
you're
if you're a celebrity you can actually
talk to people in the dms
just don't exchange nudes right away
maybe meet them
if you think you're interested in them
and you want to date them or something
maybe meet them go out see who they
are and if you like them and then you
can probably good advice even if you're
not a celebrity
thank you just don't immediately send
nudes to the people that you need yeah
i'm not saying you can't date a fan or
whatever that mean that happens a lot
especially if you're really famous
that's famous should be at least aware
that they have
a power dynamic over that person
they just gotta trade yeah you gotta be
careful you have to be careful with that
power because
a lot of people want to whatever
i'm out
bye-bye
thanks everybody we'll see you next
uh it'll be up week monday night for
members and another h3 podcast coming
out thursday
the best podcast in the world
bye-bye
[Music]
on the sleeve shredder will stop off him
all freighters at the suite we'll do the
real raw ritual with more
and e.t share a laugh with the ringer
see how low jimmy lee
they said we wouldn't come back but we
always do embrace from the ashes like
the phoenix on the flex back to two
you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three three
you're watching h to the three three